d'avoir répondu à l'invitation de notre
commission d'enquête visant à établir
les raisons de la perte de la
souveraineté et de l'indépendance
énergétique de la France nous venons de
commencer nos travaux puisque notre
commission s'est installée la semaine
dernière que nous avons eu une première
audition tout à l'heure avec une
anthropologue un historien de l'énergie
et aujourd'hui nous cherchons à brosser
de façon générale un paysage le paysage
énergétique de la France avant
progressivement d'entrer plus en détail
dans le dans le processus décisionnel
alors Monsieur Jean-Côme ici vous êtes
professeur a mis une ParisTech vous êtes
membre du Haut Conseil pour le climat
pardon
vous étiez alors
amine Paris pardon mine Paris vous étiez
vous êtes membre du Haut Conseil pour le
climat fondateur du shift projet merci
d'avoir répondu à notre demande
d'audition dans des délais extrêmement
contraints qui sont liés à l'agenda de
l'installation de notre de notre
commission vous êtes par ailleurs
relativement connu des Français pour
vous exprimer régulièrement des sur les
sujets d'énergie dans les médias et nous
allons vous donc vous donner sans tarder
la parole pour nous exposer
votre analyse pour un propos introductif
et puis ensuite il y aura des questions
de ma part du rapporteur et puis de la
commission mais en amont s'agissant
d'une commission d'enquête et en vertu
de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre
1958 relatives au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires vous devez
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité monsieur
jean-clau ici je vous prie donc de lever
la main droite et de dire je le jure je
le jure merci et je vous laisse donc la
parole pour un propos introductif très
bien en fait mon propos introductif va
être relativement bref parce que
j'imagine que c'est surtout vous qui
avez des questions je vais juste faire
deux commentaires un sur mes titres et
ce au nom duquel je m'exprime ou pas
et le deuxième commentaire que je vais
faire c'est sur l'intitulé même de la
commission d'enquête
en ce qui concerne mes titres donc je
précise que je ne m'exprime au nom
d'aucune des instances pour lesquelles
mon figure ici donc je ne suis pas du
tout habilité à m'exprimer au nom du
Haut Conseil pour le climat qui a une
présidente qui fait ça très bien je suis
pas plus habilité à m'exprimer au nom
des mines ni au nom de carbone cap donc
ce que je vais vous raconter aujourd'hui
n'engage pas carbone 4 et ni au nom du
chiffre project voilà ça n'engagera que
moi la deuxième chose que je souhaite
préciser en ce qui concerne le titre
même de votre commission la France n'a
jamais été indépendante énergétiquement
depuis qu'elle a quitté l'air des
énergies renouvelables c'est à dire que
nous étions indépendant énergétiquement
à l'époque où nous utilisions
exclusivement les pierres et le bois du
sol français pour construire des moulins
à vent les pierres du sol français
pourri de bois pour construire des
moulins à eau et le bois français et
l'herbe française pour faire avancer des
animaux de traits depuis que nous sommes
rentrés dans l'ère des combustibles
fossiles et de l'énergie nucléaire et
des nouvelles énergies renouvelables etc
en fait nous ne sommes pas indépendants
parce que nous dépend d'une espèce
d'imbrication des énergies je sais pas
si l'historiens des énergies qui est
venu ici c'est Jean-Baptiste Fressoz non
c'est pas lui mais sinon en fait il y a
une implication des énergies qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dégager
une énergie de façon individualisée d'un
système elles sont toutes imbriquées et
par exemple on ne fait pas de réacteurs
nucléaire sans métallurgie donc sans
charbon on ne fait pas de panneaux
photovoltaïques sans électricité au
charbon donc son charbon on ne fait pas
on ne fait pas venir depuis la Chine
sans pétrole parce que il faut que ça
vienne donc en fait il y a une
implication des énergies aujourd'hui et
sauf à ce qu'un pays maîtrise sur son
sol la totalité à la fois des sources
énergétiques impliquées donc la totalité
des énergies actuellement utilisées dans
le monde et la totalité des mines
métalliques qui sont nécessaires pour
fournir les dispositifs d'extraction de
l'énergie de l'environnement et de
transformation en des vecteurs
énergétiques qui permettent d'alimenter
nos machines et bien on ne peut pas
parler d'indépendance énergétique ou de
souveraineté énergétique donc en fait
aucun pays ne la possède totalement
l'Arabie saoudite a plus de pétrole que
nous mais elle a pas de mine de fer donc
si elle était à frontière fermée sans
aucune communication avec l'extérieur il
ne pourrait pas exploiter son pétrole
voilà donc c'était juste un petit une
petite remarque préliminaire pour dire
que les mots ayant un sens enfin en tout
cas j'imagine qu'ils en ont un dans la
Commission dans le titre de la
commission d'enquête
je voulais juste faire remarquer que
l'indépendance ça n'existe pas stricte
au sang et que la bonne question pour
moi me semble être pour l'ensemble du
système énergétique de savoir de qui on
dépend
dans quelle proportion avec quelle
aptitude à ce retourner si jamais on a
un problème avec les gens dont on dépend
voilà c'est ça les bonnes questions et
donc c'est des questions qui sont
nécessairement quantifiées et calendez
avoir un débat c'est pas du tout
agressif ce que je veux dire mais avoir
un débat philosophique sur
l'indépendance en fait c'est très
intéressant le soir passé 23 heures mais
sinon dans l'absolu ça n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt pratique
et je vais finir ce petit exposé
luminaire en rappelant que la France
quand on regarde ce qu'on appelle
l'énergie finale c'est-à-dire l'énergie
qui alimente les machines qui nous
rendent la vie si douce qu'il s'agisse
des ascenseurs des tractopelles des
trains ou des laminoirs l'essentiel de
l'énergie qui rentre dans une machine en
France qui nous rend un service quelle
qu'elle soit que ce soit de la mobilité
de etc c'est des combustible fossiles et
que la France sauf erreur de ma part ne
possède plus du tout de gigantesque sur
son sol et possède 1% enfin extra
extrait de l'environnement 1% du pétrole
qu'elle consomme
je vais également faire un petit rappel
j'avais dans alors pas dans l'hémicycle
ni dans cette salle mais dans une autre
salle de l'Assemblée il y a très très
longtemps participé à un colloque
organisé par Yves Cochet qui avait fait
rigoler tout le monde à l'époque sur le
pic de production du pétrole ça devait
être une quinzaine d'années je crois je
voudrais rappeler que le pic de
production du pétrole depuis est passé
en ce qui concerne le pétrole
conventionnel c'est-à-dire que tout ce
qui n'est pas le shaila et l'américain
et les sables bitume Canadiens est passé
par un maximum en 2008 dans le monde il
y a un lien direct avec ce qu'on a
appelé la crise des subprimes que depuis
sa décline et que en ce qui concerne
l'Europe l'Europe est en
approvisionnement contraint à la baisse
sur son pétrole depuis cette date
ça c'est quelque chose qui est
géologique d'accord que ça nous plaise
ou que ça nous plaise pas ça va
s'accélérer dans les décennies qui
viennent et en particulier il y a un
travail très complet qui a été fait par
le shit projet qui est public qui est
disponible sur notre site qui porte sur
les possibilités de production de
pétrole sous sol contraintes géologique
des 16 premiers fournisseurs de l'Europe
qui sont par ailleurs les 16 premiers
producteurs mondiaux hors Brésil et
Canada et la conclusion de ce travail
qui a été menée par deux anciens cadres
dirigeants total et pas n'importe
lesquels puisqu'il s'agissait de la
personne qui était en charge de
l'évaluation des gisements et la
l'exploration c'est que la production de
nos 16 premiers fournisseurs devraient
divisés par deux d'ici à 2050 ce qui
veut dire que leurs exportations vers
l'Europe vont être divisés par n'importe
quoi entre 2 et 20
donc de la perte de souveraineté sur le
pétrole faut s'attendre à en avoir et
pas qu'un peu en ce qui concerne le gaz
le ship project va publier en novembre
dans quelques jours là un travail
similaire qu'on a fait sur le gaz confié
à des personnes de même tabac avec des
données qui sont en qui sont issues du
même endroit c'est-à-dire une base de
données de l'ensemble des gisements de
pétrole et de gaz dans le monde qu'elle
a quel on a eu accès
et le résultat de ce travail c'est que
le pic de production pour le gaz dans le
monde dans son ensemble c'est 2030 celui
pour la mer du Nord c'était 2005 donc si
on ajoute à ça le fait que le charbon
est en déplétion géologique en Europe
depuis 1950 enfin me payer les années 50
en gros en fait sur toutes les énergies
fossiles l'Europe étant entre guillemets
perte de souveraineté
depuis
2005 pour le gaz
2008 pour le pétrole et les années 50
pour le charbon avant même qu'il y ait
des sujets de climat voilà c'est dans ce
donc il faut bien voir que en fait sur
les énergies fossiles qui sont le
premier moteur de la civilisation dans
lequel nous vivons la question de la
perte de souveraineté elle est déjà à
l'oeuvre depuis longtemps et ça va
s'accélérer et ça va se traduire
directement en contraction de flux de
toute nature que l'on a l'habitude de
résumer classiquement sous l'angle PIB
mais voilà on va avoir un sujet de
contraction des flux de toute façon on
en est en vie ou pas
merci beaucoup pour ce propos
introductif qui qui pose tout de suite
le cadre moi j'aurais du coup quelques
quelques questions avant de laisser la
parole aux rapporteur d'abord une
première question finalement au-delà de
la souveraineté et de l'indépendance
aujourd'hui la dans le débat public et
dans le dans la situation aussi dans
laquelle on se trouve dans les dans les
contraintes pour pour les choix
énergétiques à venir il y a la question
du climat et elle est même centrale et
donc du cycle du cycle carbone
très long sur les énergies fossiles plus
court sur la biomasse absent sur sur les
énergies renouvelables ou sur ou sur le
nucléaire quel est pour vous à l'échelle
du climat le pas de temps acceptable du
cycle carbone pourquoi est-ce que le
bois serait acceptable alors que le
charbon ne l'est pas est-ce que vous
pouvez un peu nous détailler ça
oui alors une toute petite remarque
incidente sur votre question en fait les
énergies renouvelables et nucléaires ne
sont pas sans carbone si on regarde en
analyse de cycle de vie puisque comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure il faut du
Charbon Pour faire la métallurgie amont
il faut de la pétrochimie pour faire la
fin de la chimie organique pour faire la
chimie à l'amont etc après il faut
compter et le résultat du décompte n'est
pas le même en ce qui concerne les
différentes énergies renouvelables le
nucléaire etc
la le pas de temps acceptable en général
on raisonne dans le domaine climatique
au pas de temps de l'année c'est-à-dire
que à partir du moment où une émission
et une reprise de l'atmosphère ont lieu
la même année on considère que c'est
neutre c'est ça le c'est ça en général
ce qu'on considère alors en ce qui
concerne les combustibles fossiles les
combustibles fossiles stockent du
carbone qui a été retiré à l'atmosphère
il y a quelques dizaines à quelques
centaines de millions d'années c'est à
peu près le temps qu'il faut pour faire
du gaz du charbon ou du pétrole à partir
de résidus de vie ancienne des fougères
qui ont poussé au carbonifères pour le
charbon et du plancton qui s'est
développé dans la mer n'importe quand
entre il y a 5 millions d'années pour
une petite partie mais surtout n'importe
quand entre 100 et 400 millions d'années
pour le pétrole et gaz puis c'est
résidus de vie anciennes ont été
enfouies par la tectonique des plaques
sous le sol gentiment distillées par la
géothermie
et tout ça a pris quelques dizaines à
quelques centaines de millions d'années
ce qui veut dire que quand on déstocke
ce carbone accumulé ces poches de soleil
anciennes comme dit très joliment Yann
Arthus-Bertrand dans l'atmosphère quand
on les déstocke et qu'on les remet dans
l'atmosphère on crée une asymétrie entre
le rythme auquel la vie peut reprendre
du carbone de l'atmosphère et le rythme
auquel nous on Déstock le carbone qui
avait été anciennement stocké pour la
biomasse en fait la biomasse n'est pas
nécessairement neutre en carbone c'est
toute la difficulté du décompte ça
dépend dans quel stock on tape
pour que la biomasse soit considérée
comme neutre en carbone il faut taper
dans un stock qui si on ne tape pas
dedans serait à l'équilibre avec chaque
année une partie des arbres qui meurent
on va dire et de jeunes arbres qui
repoussent et à partir du moment où on
prélève dans un stock qui est à
l'équilibre moins que ce qu'on appelle
la crue forestier annuel c'est-à-dire la
quantité de biomasse qui se forme par
photosynthèse à ce moment on considère
qu'on a affaire à une énergie
renouvelable si on prélève plus à ce
moment on a affaire de la déforestation
et c'est pas du tout compter dans les
énergies renouvelables ces comptes et
alors c'est toute la difficulté c'est
que dans une partie des réglementations
qui poussent à l'utilisation de la
biomasse en fait on n'est pas capable de
mettre des seuils c'est-à-dire qu'on
n'est pas capable de dire on va
favoriser l'appel à la biomasse jusqu'à
tel niveau parce que après on bascule
dans la déforestation et par ailleurs il
y a quelque chose dont on sait très mal
tenir compte dans ce genre de cas de
figure qui est l'effet les effets domino
ou les effets de transfert je vais vous
donner un exemple aujourd'hui on
considère que le colza qu'on fait
pousser en france pour faire des
agrocarburants c'est de la biomasse
neutre en carbone mais moi je pourrais
vous dire on pourrait très bien à la
place de ce colza ne pas faire pousser
de colza diminuer la taille des voitures
et par ailleurs à la place du colza
faire pousser du soja et de la luzerne
et éviter dans n'importe quel du Brésil
et comme ça éviter de la déforestation
bon donc vous voyez dans le deuxième cas
de figure je peux considérer que le
colza paraît fait d'éviction empêche de
mettre en France des cultures qui elles
vont engendrer de la déforestation
du coup est-ce que je considère que ce
colza il est neutre en carbone ou pas
vous voyez ce genre de donc il y a plein
de questions de méthode qui sont très
compliquées quand il s'agit de faire
appel à la biomasse et en tout état de
cause si on raisonne à l'échelle
planétaire au moment actuellement à
l'échelle planétaire la terre est en
déforestation ce qui veut dire que à
chaque fois que on met quelque part une
culture énergétique bah on peut se dire
que c'est comme c'est la culture
marginale c'est la dernière qu'on met en
oeuvre c'est elle qui est responsable
d'une partie de la déforestation qu'on
pourrait éviter sinon si on mettait pas
en oeuvre cette culture voilà donc c'est
c'est compliqué les raisonnements sur la
biomasse il y a rien de très simple
là-dedans
du coup est-ce que pour décarboner
à l'échelle de la planète à notre notre
économie est-ce que le seul chemin c'est
celui de la décroissance
je pense que c'est quelque chose qu'on
ne va pas réussir à éviter et en fait
quand on regarde les flux physique c'est
quelque chose dans lequel nous sommes
déjà en Europe depuis 2007
2008 c'est-à-dire le passage de la de
l'approvisionnement enfin du maximum de
l'approvisionnement pétrolier si on
regarde les flux physique de quoi je
parle je parle par exemple de la
quantité de mètres carrés qu'on
construit en Europe qui est passé par un
maximum en 2007 que nous n'avons plus
jamais atteint depuis je parle des
tonnes chargés dans les camions qui sont
passés par un maximum en 2007 et qui n'a
pas été atteint de nouveau depuis je
parle éventuellement de la production
industrielle voilà quand vous regardez
donc en tant que la production
industrielle elle est mesurée en euros
donc là déjà il y a une convention on
n'est plus dans les unités strictement
physiques comme des mètres carrés ou des
tonnes là c'est beaucoup plus facile
donc il faudrait mesurer la production
industrielle en tonne aussi ou en mètre
cube ou en quelque chose de physique et
là on aurait une réponse qui serait
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus clair mais
il n'empêche que un certain nombre
d'indicateurs physiques ou de proxy
d'indicateurs physiques en fait sont
déjà en décrue en Europe depuis
2007-2008
ce qui signifie qu'en fait la
décroissance on s'en rend pas compte
mais on est déjà dedans alors quand je
dis on s'en rend pas compte les élites
urbaines comme nous ça rendent pas
compte parce que nous on fait partie des
préservés du système vous et moi on vit
dans un endroit qui est loin des flux
physique donc on vit en ville les
vêtements arrivent au magasin la
nourriture arrive au supermarché enfin
on se rend pas bien compte de ce qu'il y
a à Lamont et donc c'est voilà donc on
n'est pas on n'est pas les premiers j'ai
envie de dire à se rendre compte avec
nos sens les sens ça compte quand même
chez les animaux que nous sommes on
n'est pas les premiers à se rendre
compte avec nos sens de ce qui est en
train de se passer mais en fait on est
déjà dans une espèce de décrue larvé en
Europe et les Italiens s'en rendent très
bien compte les Espagnols et les
Portugais se rendent parfaitement compte
aussi et c'est malheureusement quelque
chose qui va s'accélérer parce que les
combustibles fossiles qui sont eux-mêmes
en décrue subis jouent un rôle tellement
central dans l'émergence de la
civilisation dans laquelle nous vivons
que cette décrue ne sera pas compensée
par
aucune autre forme d'énergie des
carbonée dans les temps
compte tenu des ordres de grandeur qui
sont en jeu donc les énergies
décarbonées vont pouvoir jouer un rôle
d'amortisseur donc c'est bien d'en faire
mais ça ne va pas complètement éviter
une remise en cause parce que les
combustibles fossiles sont absolument
partout à commencer par le vêtement que
je porte la cravate que vous portez etc
le vernis de la table sur lequel je
m'appuie tous les composants du micro
dans lequel je parle enfin il y a du
pétrole il y a des résidus de pétrole
enfin ou des dérivés du pétrole plus
exactement partout là-dedans et donc
faire une civilisation actuelle sans
combustible fossile personnellement je
n'y crois pas je pense que c'est juste
pas possible
[Musique]
donc là donc avec de moins en moins de
combustible fossiles oui on va avoir
droit à quelque chose qui s'apparentera
alors on va décroissance contractions
sobriété tout ça c'est des variantes
sémantiques d'un concept qui est
exactement le même c'est-à-dire qu'on va
devoir faire avec moi moins de choses
physiques alors est-ce que c'est une
catastrophe il nous appartient que la
réponse soit non est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
y échapper je crois pas pour des raisons
physiques aussi
alors du coup je j'ai deux questions que
je vous pose encore et puis après je
serai à parler aux rapporteur
une sur les ressources disponibles sur
notre sur notre sol
vous avez largement évoqué la quantité
de ressources qu'on importe
qu'il soit de minerais d'énergie
carbonée etc comment est-ce qu'on
mobilise des ressources sur notre sol je
pense y compris aux ressources minières
le lithium par exemple les choses comme
ça et puis deuxième question qui est
peut-être un peu détachée mais comment
comment on construit aujourd'hui des
scénarios énergétiques qui puissent être
crédibles on sort d'une période où on a
vu beaucoup de scénarios énergétiques se
contreduit contredire quelle méthode
selon vous est-ce qu'il faudrait qu'on
adopte pour construire des scénarios
énergétiques crédibles
aucune de ces deux questions n'est
simple là sur la première comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour exploiter des ressources
déjà encore faudrait-il qu'on en est
vous savez probablement que en ce qui
concerne le charbon on a plus grand
chose chez nous en ce qui concerne le
minerai de fer on a plus grand chose
chez nous je ne sais pas si on n'a
jamais eu de minerai cuivre mais je
pense pas qu'il nous en reste beaucoup
donc certes on a certaines ressources
qu'on peut exploiter donc celle-là
éventuellement le on peut le faire par
contre il y en a d'autres pour
lesquelles c'est pas du tout sûr qu'on
en est tout court après il y a une
deuxième chose qu'il faut bien voir en
ce qui concerne les ressources
métalliques c'est qu'il y a un cercle
alors je sais pas si je vois l'appeler
vicieux ou en tout cas d'asservissement
entre l'énergie et les métaux tout
simplement parce que avec le temps la
teneur en métal des minerais baisse et
ça veut dire que il faut de plus en plus
d'énergie pour produire une tonne d'un
métal donné pour vous donner un exemple
si ma mémoire ne me fait pas trop
d'effort dans les premières mines de
cuivre qui ont été exploitées dans le
monde et notamment la mine de riotito
qui a donné son nom ensuite au replinier
éponyme qui se trouve en Espagne je
crois qu'au début de exploitation
minière il y avait de l'ordre de 15 à
20% de cuivre en poids dans le minerai
aujourd'hui la teneur moyenne en cuivre
en poids dans le minerai des mines
exploitées dans le monde c'est 04% et
donc on est descendu de 20 à 0,4 et il y
a un mouvement général de baisse de la
teneur en métaux de toutes les mines
qu'on exploite dans le monde
[Musique]
et c'est évidemment pour cette raison là
que une partie des mines françaises ont
été abandonnées parce qu'il y a encore
un peu de ressources en France mais que
les mines françaises ont été abandonnées
tout simplement parce que la teneur
donnait trop basse et que du coup
c'était pas rentable en compétition avec
d'autres gisements dans le monde qui
étaient plus intéressants
donc pour accéder au pour accéder aux
métaux il faut de l'énergie et les
ressources qu'on peut éventuellement
avoir en France elles sont conditionnées
nécessairement à la quantité d'énergie
dont on peut disposer pour accéder aux
métaux en question
et par ailleurs au gisements au gisement
de départ à l'inventaire de départ
on restera nécessairement dépendant pour
partie de choses qui ne viennent pas de
France
quand on regarde par exemple les
quantités de cuivre qui sont impliqués
dans le développement de tout ce qui est
électrique il est évident qu'en France
on peut pas déployer quoi que ce soit de
significatif comme mode renouvelable ou
même pas renouvelable et comme
usage aval électrique sans importer du
cuivre c'est pas possible alors ça sera
peut-être facile ce sera peut-être
difficile j'en sais rien sur le cuivre
il y a une information qui a été publiée
par l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
il y a pas très longtemps 10 ans que les
mines de cuivre en fonctionnement dans
le monde et celles qui sont en cours de
développement donc en cours de
développement ça veut dire que les
infrastructures d'exploitation du
minerai sont en cours de construction
passeraient leur pic entre maintenant et
dans deux ans
et pour ajouter des nouvelles mines
c'est-à-dire pour que des nouveaux
projets voient le jour il faut compter
entre 10 et 15 ans
voilà donc il y a un petit sujet alors
ça m'amène du coup à la deuxième
question qui est comment est-ce qu'on
fait des scénarios crédibles et ben la
réponse c'est très compliqué
aux chiffres project on avait
modestement fait un discours de la
méthode sur les scénarios électriques
qui nous a valu ensuite d'avoir des
dialogues très nourris et très fructueux
avec RTE sur la scénarisation électrique
donc nous on n'avait pas proposé un
scénario on avait proposé un mode de
réalisation des scénarios en disant pour
que le scénario soit complet avec le
décideur arrive à retrouver ses petits
il faut absolument prendre position sur
tel point tel point tel point tel point
tel point à tel point à tel point et
bien préciser ce qui est une donnée
d'entrée ce qui est une donnée de sortie
voilà alors dans les scénarios
énergétiques il y a aujourd'hui une
faiblesse qui est partagée par à peu
près tous les scénarios qui est que
l'économie est une donnée d'entrée
dans mon point de vue l'économie est une
donnée de sortie c'est parce que nous
avons des ressources que nous sommes
capables d'avoir un système économique
donc l'économie vient d'un système
productif donc un système économique si
il n'y avait pas d'atomes de fer sur
terre bah il y aurait pas d'immeubles en
tout cas pas d'immeuble tels que nous
les construisons aujourd'hui avec des
armatures en fer donc la disponibilité
des ressources est une condition est un
facteur limitant
de la production économique
et du coup le la croissance du PIB c'est
une c'est dans ma vision à moi tel que
ça devrait exister dans l'économie alors
j'ai pas dit tout ça ça devrait être une
donnée de sortie d'un modèle dans lequel
on entrait vous mettez les ressources
disponibles et le nombre de gens
capables de travailler c'est ça que vous
devriez mettre en entrée puis derrière
vous avez une production économique or
dans tous les scénarios énergétiques que
je connais en général l'économie est une
donnée d'entrée et l'énergie est quelque
chose qui est appelé par une économie
dont la création vient de mars bon alors
ça c'est une faiblesse qui est partagée
par à peu près tous les scénarios y
compris le scénario de RTE et une autre
faiblesse dans beaucoup de scénarios
économiques c'est qu'on postule que les
prix d'aujourd'hui sont prédictifs de
l'absence de limite ou de limite sur les
quantités de demain dit autrement si ça
vaut pas cher aujourd'hui c'est que
demain on en aura sans limite
bon et ça c'est une deuxième faiblesse
puisque malheureusement les prix d'hier
ne sont absolument pas prédictifs des
quantités de demain on est en train de
le voir en ce moment avec le gaz le gaz
valait pas cher du tout il y a un an et
demi et ça veut pas du tout dire que on
va avoir les du gaz sans problème pour
les deux hivers qui viennent donc c'est
celui-ci plus le suivant donc et celui
d'après du reste donc c'est c'est ça
c'est des faiblesses un peu partagées
par tous les scénarios c'est le fait
qu'on a du mal à désimbriquer l'économie
de la partie strictement physique dans
les scénarios énergétiques après j'ai
envie de dire les autres faiblesses
elles sont un peu plus secondaires mais
alors du coup ça veut dire que les
scénarios énergétiques qu'on fait
aujourd'hui il y en a aucun qui soit
résistant à la récession c'est à dire
que en gros si on se trouve dans un
monde dans lequel nos moyens sont
physiques sont en décroissance
la question de savoir si le scénario
énergétique est toujours réaliste est
une question qui n'est pas tranchée
d'une manière générale dans l'ensemble
des scénarios il y a pas ça et ce qui
est très étonnant c'est que même les
scénarios de sobriété par exemple le
scénario 2050 de l'ADEME qui viennent
d'être publié sont des scénarios dans
lesquels il y a de la croissance
économique
voilà donc de mon point de vue à ce
niveau là il y a une contradiction
monsieur
le président merci Monsieur jean-covici
pour ses premiers mots
énergiques dans la continuité des
questions du président peut-être
reprendre ce que vous avez dit en
introduction sur laquelle la manière
dont vous avez qualifié l'absence
d'indépendance énergétique de tout temps
enfin en tout cas depuis très très
longtemps dans notre pays et vous
demandez peut-être de qualifier
l'évolution de cette dépendance depuis
la prière
elle a alors au sens de la valeur
ajoutée elle a baissé la dépendance
puisque on a coutume de considérer le
nucléaire comme étant une production
domestique alors en termes de valeur
ajoutée c'est tout à fait exact enfin
c'est très largement exact il faut
importer moins d'un euro d'uranium par
mégawatt-heure électrique produit avec
du nucléaire en France donc
effectivement dans un méga water
nucléaire qui coûte 50 euros on peut
considérer que enfin en ordre de
grandeur on peut considérer que 1 euro
c'est une part qui est parfaitement
négligeable
si on raisonne en termes de dépendance
c'est-à-dire si l'étranger n'existait
pas est-ce qu'on pourrait toujours faire
fonctionner le système français à ce
moment on n'est pas plus indépendant sur
le nucléaire que sur le reste par contre
on n'est pas dépendant de la même
manière et en particulier si je compare
aux hydrocarbures on a un confort j'ai
envie de dire temporel qui n'est pas
exactement le même en ce qui concerne
les 0 carbures comme vous le savez
probablement on a trois mois de stock en
France c'est-à-dire que si demain matin
tous nos fournisseurs nous coupe les
vivres sur le pétrole le pays fonctionne
trois mois et puis s'arrête alors en
fait il s'arrêtera même bien avant parce
qu'il y a des stocks stratégiques qu'on
utilisera pas parce que on les gardera
pour l'armée les ambulances et je sais
pas quoi donc très vite le pays s'arrête
en ce qui concerne l'uranium on peut
stocker des années de fonctionnement sur
le sol et des années ça laisse un peu
plus de temps pour se retourner si on a
un problème avec un fournisseur que
trois mois
sur le voilà donc en gros on a en
passant des hydrocarbures au nucléaires
ce qui est la décision qu'on a prise
dans la production électrique dans les
années 60-70
bien évidemment nous avons gagné en
confort
stricto sensu on peut pas dire qu'on est
gagné en indépendance par contre on a
gagné en confort et on a gagné en part
de valeur ajoutée qui est réalisé sur le
sol français versus ce qui est fait à
l'étranger on a aussi gagné même si
c'était pas le but à l'époque mais du
coup c'est quand même un atout précieux
sur les émissions de CO2
merci beaucoup est-ce que si je reprends
ce que vous venez de dire en prospectif
ça veut dire que un réinvestissement de
la filière nucléaire ou bien à
technologie constante ou marginalement
évolutive si on prend les EPR ou
technologie différente avec les neutrons
rapides ou très différentes avec la
fusion on pourrait on pourrait on ne
gagnerait qu'en confort à nouveau mais
pas en indépendance
c'est bon
alors on ne gâtent stricto sensu on ne
gagnerait toujours pas en indépendance
parce que par exemple pour faire une
centrale nucléaire il faut du chrome on
n'a pas de chrome en France il faut du
cuivre on n'a pas de cuivre en France
donc c'est toujours pareil si on veut
être stricte sur les termes non on ne
gagne pas on indépendant on a toujours
besoin d'un fournisseur étranger mais on
gagne en confort
on gagne en confort et on gagne en
quantité alors en ce qui concerne le
cuivre si mes derniers chiffres sont
exacts parce qu'il y avait un document
de l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
qui donnait ça il me semble que le
rapport entre le solaire et le nucléaire
c'est de l'ordre de grandeur c'est plus
de 10 sur la quantité de cuivre par
kilowatt-heure produit
donc dans un cas comme dans l'autre si
on veut faire du décarboné on a on est
moins dépendant si on fait du nucléaire
que si on fait un système solaire et
d'une manière générale les énergies
renouvelables qui exploitent des sources
diffuses donc le vent et le soleil ont
besoin de plus de collecteurs
pour avoir la même quantité d'énergie à
l'arrivée sans parler du fait qu'en plus
il faut concentrer parce qu'aujourd'hui
on vit dans une civilisation de la
puissance donc on a besoin de sources
concentrées il faut enfin en tout cas si
on veut maintenir un système qui est pas
trop éloigné du système actuel d'après
on peut débattre d'autres choses
il faut concentrer et il faut
éventuellement stocker parce que les
hydrocarbures assurent également la
fonction de stock j'ai envie de dire par
construction
tout ça demande également des moyens
supplémentaires et donc à chaque fois
des métaux en plus
donc stricto sensu développé la filière
nucléaire je le répète c'est pas être
indépendant puisqu'on a toujours besoin
de fournisseurs de métaux étrangers
c'est moins dépendant au niveau des
métaux que d'autres options
dans les dans les trois choses que vous
avez citées alors il y en a une qu'on
peut exclure tout de suite c'est la
fusion
la fusion mes enfants seront morts que
ce sera toujours pas quelque chose qui
va changer la donne de façon
significative dans l'approvisionnement
électrique des carbonée je voudrais
quand même rappeler que ITER aujourd'hui
c'est un dispositif qui a seulement pour
objet
de produire un peu plus d'énergie avec
la fusion du plasma que l'énergie qui a
été nécessaire pour mettre le placement
en chauffe à quelques millions de degrés
par ailleurs ITER ne comporte aucun
dispositif électrogène et je ne sais pas
si aujourd'hui on sait faire un
dispositif électrogène avec du
rayonnement gamma et des neutrons
puisque c'est essentiellement ça qu'on
va récupérer d'un réacteur à fusion
alors que dans un réacteur affiché on
récupère de l'eau chaude c'est quand
même un peu plus simple
donc le voilà donc ITER
on oublie ça va pas changer grand chose
avant que les gens dans cette salle ne
passe de vie à très peu
en ce qui concerne la quatrième
génération pour moi c'est le gros
déterminant du fait que on est un
nucléaire entre guillemets durable à
l'avenir ou pas
le nucléaire qu'on exploite aujourd'hui
exploite comme vous le savez
probablement un isotope très minoritaire
de l'uranium l'uranium 235 qui est
présent à environ 07% dans l'uranium
naturel
les quantités
récupérables d'uranium sur Terre en
ordre de grandeur
font que si on voulait remplacer
toujours sur terre si on raisonne CO2
une fraction significative des centrales
à charbon mondial par de l'uranium par
du nucléaire il y a pas assez d'uranium
de 135 pour que ce truc là flotte
pendant des siècles
il n'a pas assez donc il faut absolument
si on veut que le nucléaire soit durable
passer à la quatrième génération qui
elle est capable d'exploiter soit
l’uranium 238 soit du thorium
et il faut le faire dans pas trop
longtemps parce que pour démarrer ces
réacteurs de quatrième génération on a
quand même besoin du seul matériau
ficile qu'on trouve sur terre qui est
l’uranium 235 donc le jour où il y a
plus d'uranium 235 du tout c'est
évidemment caricatural comme mais pour
bien faire comprendre on ne peut plus
démarrer de réacteurs de quatrième
génération c'est plus possible
est-ce que si la France passait à la
quatrième génération on augmenterait
notre indépendance oui on serait capable
d'exploiter les stocks d'uranium 238
qu'on a accumulé très bien mais en fait
ça ne change pas grand chose dans le
panorama d'ensemble parce que je le
redis on continue à avoir besoin
d'importer d'autres métaux pour
construire les réacteurs pour etc et le
poids de l'uranium dans l'affaire est
pas quelque chose d'absolument
fondamental
mais l'argument premier pour passer à la
quatrième génération il est pas qu'on a
accumulé des stocks d'uranium 238 en
France il est que à l'échelle mondiale
j'ai envie de dire c'est le seul
nucléaire qui puisse être réellement
durable
pour continuer dans le panorama que vous
faites vous avez parlé des hydrocarbures
fin des fossiles en général là du
nucléaire et peut-être vous pouvez nous
dresser le tableau pour un certain
nombre d'énergie renouvelables à la fois
en capacité en capacité à sécuriser les
approvisionnements à moyen terme et puis
bien sûr en capacité de métaux et de
fiabilité
en ce qui concerne les énergies
renouvelables la France elle est avec
une un trio de tête qui ressemble
beaucoup à ce qu'on a dans le monde
puisque les trois premières énergies
renouvelables dans le monde sont alors
sous réserve de ce que j'ai dit en
ouverture sur la déforestation d'abord
la biomasse c'est la première énergie
renouvelable qu'on utilise dans le monde
ensuite arrive l'hydroélectricité c'est
à dire le l'exploitation des fleuves
et en troisième arrive l'éolien et en
fait en France on a le même trio de tête
c'est-à-dire que la première énergie
renouvelable en français le bois la
deuxième c'est le
l'hydroélectricité et la troisième
maintenant c'est l'éolien
les perspectives pour ces différentes
énergies renouvelables sont assez
différentes alors en ce qui concerne le
bois ces conditionné par l'évolution de
la forêt or notre forêt elle va être
mise à mal par le réchauffement
climatique à condition climatiques
stabilisée c'est-à-dire si demain matin
le réchauffement s'arrêtait on a quand
même 10% de la forêt française qui va
mourir
dans un monde à 2 degrés on se rapproche
plutôt de 40 ou 50%
des espèces actuelles vous avez le être
qui disparaît quasiment vous avez une
bonne partie des chaînes qui vont
disparaître vous avez l'épicéa qui
disparaît en pleine une bonne partie des
sapins qui disparaissent etc donc et
quand je dis ça je me réfère à des
simulations qui ont été faites avec
toutes les réserves qu'on peut avoir
sachant que ces dernières années ce qui
s'est vraiment passé en France est allé
plutôt plus vite du mauvais côté de la
barrière que les simulations dont
j'avais connaissance il y a 10 ans donc
c'est voilà malheureusement le j'ai
envie de dire l'évolution elle est
plutôt plus désagréable que l'idée qu'on
pouvait s'en faire
et si on commence à avoir un
dépérissement forestier généralisé avoir
beaucoup de biomasse enfin oui on aura
les arbres morts mais après on aura plus
rien quoi donc ça ça c'est quelque chose
qui est voilà il y a cette hypothèque là
sur l'approvisionnement en biomasse en
ce qui concerne l'hydroélectricité on va
avoir un stress hydrique là aussi qui va
nous desservir puisque globalement les
simulations en ce qui concerne le
réchauffement climatique montre un
assèchement sur le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen dont les Alpes au sens
large font partie enfin le en
particulier la partie sud donc il va y
avoir un sujet
en fait ça peut remonter même assez au
nord puisque cette année je sais pas si
vous avez vu passer cette information et
la Norvège à des réservoirs de barrages
qui sont très mal remplis donc la
sécheresse est allée suffisamment au
Nord en Europe pour que la Norvège
évoque même la possibilité d'exporter
moins d'électricité que d'habitude ce
qui a fait hurler le Danemark qui a
besoin des échanges avec la Norvège pour
équilibrer l'intermittence de son parc
éolien extrêmement développé
donc l'hydroélectricité est un voilà il
y a un sujet et on peut pas tellement la
développer beaucoup plus en France alors
on peut faire de la micro hydraulique
mais le dictionnaire est bien fait
micro-hydraulique ça fait des
micro-productions donc même si on fait
beaucoup de micro-production à l'arrivée
ça fait pas quelque chose qui va changer
significativement la donne à l'échelle
française c'est toujours bon à prendre
là où on peut le faire sans engendrer de
nuisances écologique éventuellement
remettre des mettre des alternateurs sur
sa tête en haut de moulin etc mais ça va
pas faire des volumes considérables
après arrive les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables alors arrivent de
contributions en particulier les pompes
à chaleur et l'éolien
en ce qui concerne l'éolien c'est très
simple on compte l'énergie électrique
qui sort d'une éolienne quand les pales
sont mises en mouvement par la force du
vent
la limite les alors là l'avantage de
l'éolien c'est qu'effectivement une fois
construite l'éolienne n'engendrent pas
des missions
les limites sont que comme ça exploite
une énergie relativement diffuse parce
que l'air c'est pas très dense voilà
donc e=mi de MV2 donc dans un mètre cube
d'air en mouvement il y a pas beaucoup
d'énergie cinétique
et donc il faut construire beaucoup
d'éoliennes pour récupérer des quantités
significatives d'électricité ça veut
dire avoir beaucoup de projets
et donc à ce moment il y a beaucoup
d'endroits où il y a des gens qui sont
éventuellement capables de discuter
alors on peut soit leur dire vous
discutez pas soit discuter les deux
options des avantages et des
inconvénients et ensuite le vent n'est
pas toujours régulier en permanence
et une éolienne il faut savoir que ça
puissance dépend du cube du vent donc si
vous divisez la vitesse du vent par deux
la puissance électrique fournie est
divisée par 8
ce qui veut dire que et quand vous
regardez à l'échelle de l'Europe même
avec l'interconnexion de toutes les
éoliennes européennes l'ensemble du parc
éolien européen peut descendre à deux
rarement mais il y a quelques moments
dans l'année où il descend à moins de 5%
de la puissance installée pour
l'ensemble de l'Europe donc on ne peut
pas avoir un système qui est purement
éolien
et même en rajoutant du soleil qui est
un peu contracyclique par rapport à
l'éolien parce que vous avez plutôt de
l'éolien de l'hiver quand il y a peu de
soleil et plutôt du soleil l'été quand
il y a peu de vent donc vous avez deux
systèmes contracycliques enfin un peu
contracyclique l'ensemble des deux ne
permet qu'en toujours pas d'avoir un
approvisionnement garanti
donc quand on donc c'est donc ces
énergies là elles ont comme limite une
limite en emplacement il faut avoir
beaucoup d'emplacements et une limite en
matériaux c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure puisque elles sont beaucoup plus
intensives en métal que les modes
centralisés
que nous avons l'habitude d'utiliser
jusqu'à maintenant
donc c'est des limites qui sont plutôt
physiques à contrario des limites du
nucléaire qui sont plutôt des limites de
compétences
et de consensus j'ai envie de dire la
limite côté nucléaire elle est plus du
côté de la volonté humaine la limite
côté nouvelle énergie renouvelables et
plus du côté des barrières physiques si
je si je voilà je suis pas en train de
dire que la volonté humaine c'est une
limite qui est plus simple à franchir
peut-être pas dire ce que j'ai pas dit
elle peut être beaucoup plus compliqué
mais
les pompes à chaleur ça exploite le
transfert d'énergie entre
l'environnement et l'intérieur d'un
logement ou l'intérieur d'une usine
parce qu'on peut faire des pompes à
chaleur haute température pour les
procédés industriels pour faire de la
vapeur industrielle
avec un cycle thermodynamique qui se
trouve à voir en général l'avantage
d'avoir un rendement supérieur
c'est-à-dire que pour 1 kWh
d'électricité que vous injectez dans la
machine vous transférez plusieurs
kilowattheure de chaleur entre
l'extérieur et l'intérieur d'un logement
c'est une contribution aujourd'hui qui
commence à devenir significative mais
c'est une énergie renouvelable c'est un
peu un paradoxe qui a besoin
d'électricité pour être mise en oeuvre
et donc moi j'avais fait un petit calcul
d'ordre de grandeur si on voulait
remplacer l'ensemble du chauffage au gaz
dans ce pays par des pompes à chaleur
après avoir préalablement isolé
l'ensemble des bâtiments
on en a quand même pour quelques
dizaines de terrawattheure d'électricité
à trouver on peut les trouver
enfin on peut les trouver on peut
décider de les faire mais voilà c'est
pas quelque chose quand même qu'on va
trouver sous le pied d'un cheval
après arrive des contributions qui sont
plus mineures dans lesquels on va
trouver les agro-carburants on va
trouver le solaire on va trouver la
géothermie voilà on va trouver des
choses comme ça qui sont qui sont plus
marginales
il y a aucune de ces énergies
renouvelables
pour lesquelles on puisse se dire quand
on regarde bien
il y a pas de problème à leur expansion
indéfinie
voilà c'est ça le problème
une dernière question enfin un paquet de
questions pour ma part qui a plus très à
votre expérience et votre participation
au débat public depuis de nombreuses
années le discours sur les énergies
nucléaires sur la production d'énergie
nucléaire en France a beaucoup varié
patient prend une borne arbitraire des
années 80 à aujourd'hui de la
préparation à la fermeture de super
phénix des décisions prises dans les
années 2000 jusqu'à la fermeture de la
centrale de Fessenheim jusqu'au jusqu'au
discours du président de la République
de Belfort en tant que participant au
débat public à la fois avec les
décideurs politiques mais aussi dans les
universités dans le débat public qu'elle
regarde vous portez sur toutes ces
évolutions et à quelle cause quelle
cause vous lui attribuer attribuer
je me méfie beaucoup de en ce qui me
concerne du fait que je vois midi à ma
porte comme beaucoup de gens quand on
regarde les sondages sur les Français et
l'énergie en fait on se rend compte que
ce qui va beaucoup compter c'est le prix
et après il y a beaucoup d'autres trucs
qui comptent quand même beaucoup moins
ce que je constate quand même c'est que
les systèmes énergétiques qui vivent sur
un pas de temps qui n'est pas celui de
la démocratie donc en gros
le gros problème des débats sur
l'énergie
c'est que il porte toujours sur des pas
de temps qui sont un ordre de grandeur
en dessous
de ce qu'il faudrait regarder
et là en fait on va déjà payer le prix
d'une partie des essais erreurs qu'on a
fait dans le passé
j'ai je ne suis pas en mesure de savoir
moi-même comment expliquer très
exactement ce qui s'est passé sur les 20
dernières années donc je continue à
fouiller à essayer de me construire une
histoire je suis pas au bout de ma quête
donc je ne sais pas pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a eu un certain il y a des
épisodes isolés qu'on est capable de de
reproduire par exemple il fait
absolument aucun doute dans mon esprit
que la partie 50% de nucléaire et
fermeture de Fessenheim c'est Hollande
qui voulait un accord avec les Verts
donc ça je suis capable de le
caractériser de le dater etc c'est un
épisode mais il y a c'était exactement
pareil en ce qui concerne Jospin est
super Phénix mais par contre il y a
d'autres trucs pour lesquels je suis
c'est très difficile pour moi
d'essayer d'expliquer dans dans son
ensemble un truc par exemple que je suis
pas capable d'expliquer
c'est pourquoi est-ce que le pétrole est
si absent du débat public en France le
pic de production du pétrole tout le
monde s'en fout je redis qu'on cochait
avait organisé son coloc ici ça avait
fait rigoler tout le monde
et encore aujourd'hui quand vous
expliquez qu'on est déjà rentré en décru
subit d'approvisionnement pétrolier les
gens vous regardent avec des yeux comme
des soucoupes et on entend jamais parler
etc on a un peu commencé à parler du gaz
depuis que Monsieur Poutine nous fait
des misères mais enfin si nous avons on
en parlait pas trop donc voilà donc il y
a une focalisation sur l'électricité
dans le débat public qui ne vous aura
pas échappé
et en particulier sur un antagonisme
nucléaire et nucléaire renouvelable
renouvelable électrique je précise
puisque encore une fois la première
renouvelable en français le bois qui est
pas électrique
qui fait les choux gras de la presse et
qui nous occupe beaucoup mais il y a des
questions pour lesquelles j'ai toujours
pas de réponse je ne sais toujours pas
pourquoi est-ce que le débat public
c'est structuré avec
on se focalisant sur certains points
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a des décisions
à certains moments qui ont été prises
enfin voilà je j'ai pas j'ai pas encore
les idées totalement claires sur le
sujet mais moi
pardon les toutes dernières lorsque vous
y incitez sur le niveau d'information de
la population du grand public des
décideurs publics au sens large
en termes de connaissances du domaine
énergétique et l'implication sur les
décisions prises
il est faible
c'est pas un sujet central dans
l'information médiatique
alors c'est pas un sujet central dans la
formation médiatique
probablement parce que
c'est vu comme un bien de consommation
avant d'être vu comme le déterminant de
ce qui fait notre monde
l'énergie je le redis on en parle
les carburants on en parle parce qu'on
les achète
on comprend pas que son camion il y
aurait pas de ville
sans camion il y a pas de ville pas de
parce que vous avez pas à manger vous
avez pas de bien de consommation vous
avez rien quoi pas de ville sans camion
donc on ne parle de l'énergie que sous
l'angle du prix ce qui est quand même
extrêmement réducteur et ce qui est très
court terme
d'une façon générale dans les médias
français il y a quand même il y a un
problème de qualification technique j'ai
envie de dire alors qui se qui évolue
doucement
mais les sujets très techniques sont
toujours des sujets avec lesquels les
médias français sont pas très à l'aise
peut-être que ça tient la formation des
journalistes qui n'est pas technique
donc du coup il faut qu'il compense par
de l'expérience sur le tas pour y
arriver et ça prend du temps
peut-être que c'est dû à l'organisation
des rédactions ou l'aristocratie c'est
de service politique qui justement ne
discute pas des visser des boulons parce
que l'intendance suivra enfin je sais
pas mais il y a une c'est clair que la
qualité de l'information elle est pas
terrible et le niveau d'information de
la population n'est pas très élevé la
bonne question c'est est-ce que c'est
très différent dans les autres pays
occidentaux j'ai pas la réponse à cette
question je serai étonné que ce soit
monstrueusement différent dans
l'essentiel des pays occidentaux on va
dire je pense qu'il y a quelques pays
qui sont quand même un peu plus matures
je pense que la Grande-Bretagne est un
pays dans lequel le débat est un peu
plus éclairé mais bon c'est un peu
mais d'une manière générale le degré de
compréhension du grand public et son
degré d'implication
dans ces débats et très faible quand on
dit qu'on fait des débats publics il
faut bien voir que ça concerne une toute
petite fraction de la population si je
prends par exemple les débats là qui
sont organisés en ce moment par la CNDP
CD débats je serai curieux de voir à la
fin du débat quelle est la fraction de
la population qui aura entendu parler du
débat
mais voilà mon expérience c'est que
c'est toujours des débats qui concernent
une toute petite fraction de la
population alors c'est pas
nécessairement une bonne nouvelle mais
en tout cas c'est une donnée du problème
en ce qui concerne les décideurs et les
élus alors là j'ai envie de dire que la
situation c'est différenciée sur les 10
dernières années
je pense que le monde civil a progressé
plus vite que le monde politique
et quand je vois
les débats qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui
dans le monde politique sur ce sujet
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on est beaucoup
bougé par rapport à il y a 10 ans
quand je vois le
il y a des décisions qui peuvent être
prises mais je veux dire globalement je
trouve que on n'a pas on n'a pas où il y
a 20 ans
quand dans le monde dans la société
civile
la conscience que les temps qui
s'annoncent risque pas être très simple
et la compréhension d'un certain nombre
de choses en ce qui concerne je parle là
plutôt des décideurs en ce qui concerne
à la fois le climat et l'énergie a quand
même un peu progressé
alors on va passer aux questions des
groupes alors pour Renaissance ce qui a
quelqu'un non
[Musique]
pour le RN est-ce que quelqu'un a une
question
monsieur Tanguy
donc j'ai pas entendu votre
introduction j'ai répondu vous vos
réponses aux questions je vais me fonder
sur les travaux que j'ai lu de vous et
les nombreuses interviews que j'ai
entendu de vous notamment rebondir sur
ce que vous avez sur le pétrole bon
alors un autre modèle modeste échelle
effectivement nous aussi on essaie de
mettre le sujet du pétrole depuis plus
de 10 ans dans le débat public nous
avons échoué même là en ce moment vous
avez parlé du gaz avec Poutine le
pétrole le fait même dans le dans les
ressources financières de la Russie sont
plus importants que les que les
ressources financières liées au gaz et
pourtant même ça ça a échoué bon ça
reste on le voit bien aujourd'hui dans
les préoccupations des Français on a
encore vu avec la pénurie qu'on a subi
reste un sujet central et pourtant
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de solution
technique donc j'espère enfin l'une des
raisons de cette commission j'espère
c'est pas seulement de de critiquer pour
critiquer même si non t'en sortirait
bien c'est de de savoir ce qu'on fait
voilà bon et donc j'ai bien entendu vous
vous réflexions sur les moyens de
production
électrique électrogène alternatif mais
comment on fait voilà qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire pour le pétrole et pour
remplacer cette ce dont ce don de la
nature enfin ce dont empoisonné mais
enfin en tout cas techniquement ce don
qui a permis la société de consommation
et aussi l'amélioration des conditions
de plus grand nombre parce que bon pour
vous suivre régulièrement et le
l'impasse là pourri qu'on a dans le
débat public c'est le lien quand même
entre la hausse de niveau de vie et la
démocratie est quand même évident donc
tout le monde remet en cause visiblement
l'abaissement du niveau de vie comme une
une fatalité moi ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup c'est que je pense que ce sera
lié à une baisse de niveau démocratie
des libertés publiques qui va avec donc
le la l'importance de trouver une
solution à ce qui est permis non pas
l'enrichissement des personnes mais
juste que leur vie soit plus douce plus
agréable et Luce vivable nous préoccupe
vivement donc vous avez fait beaucoup de
critiques et les entends c'est pas une
critique du la critique mais qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire vous à votre place
qu'est-ce que vous prendrez comme option
technique sachant le panel de
technologie la France
la réponse elle est alors la réponse
longue elle figure dans les travaux qui
ont été faits par le chiffre project sur
la façon de faire évoluer le parc de
bâtiments et la mobilité quand on
regarde où sont les usages du pétrole en
France aujourd'hui en fait on a trois
grandes on a trois grands usages en
trois usages importants on va dire il y
a un usage dans la mobilité l'essentiel
du pétrole va un dans la mobilité des
marchandises et dans la mobilité des
personnes et paradoxalement on est plus
dépendant encore de la mobilité des
marchandises qui n'ont pas de jambes que
de la mobilité des personnes il y avait
il y a pas très longtemps j'avais fait
remarquer que si demain matin il y avait
une voiture sur trois seulement qui
était capable de rouler en France et
bien tout le monde gueulerait mais en
attendant on arriverait à s'organiser
quand même alors que si demain matin il
y a seulement un camion sur trois qui
roule en France on a un tout petit sujet
d'approvisionnement alimentaire donc là
il y a 30% des camions en France qui
transportent un truc qui se mange
donc le
donc le pétrole il sert d'abord à ça il
sert ensuite un peu au chauffage et
enfin il sert un peu dans l'industrie et
dans l'industrie son usage le plus
précieux et comme matière première pour
faire de la chimie organique laquelle
Chili organique va se retrouver
absolument partout dans les vêtements
dans les bâtiments dans les détergents
dans et dans j'ai envie de dire les
biens intermédiaires qui servent à tout
l'industrie à Laval
les options pour remplacer le pétrole
sont pas les mêmes en fonction de ce
qu'on regarde alors en ce qui concerne
la mobilité aussi project on a fait un
certain nombre et un certain nombre de
morceaux du plan de transformation de
l'économie française qui porte là dessus
on a à la fois analysé la mobilité
longue distance
dont la mobilité aérienne a fait l'objet
d'un rapport à part la mobilité du
quotidien la mobilité des marchandises
donc on a regardé tout ça si je fais
cours dans les conclusions il va falloir
faire avec moins de voitures parce que
l'énergie c'est un demi de MV2 donc
quand on déplace une virgule cinq tonnes
de métal ma foi on a besoin d'une
certaine quantité d'énergie et si on a
plus le pétrole les énergies
alternatives que ce soit
l'électrification les agro-carburants
etc ne permettront pas de conserver en
France 40 millions de véhicules
particuliers comme on les a aujourd'hui
c'est pas nécessairement un drame
simplement il faut pouvoir s'organiser
en conséquence non ce n'est pas
nécessairement un drame et de toute
façon on va devoir faire avec donc je
confère ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure à
la question sur la croissance donc après
on peut taper du pied et se rouler par
terre mais ça changera strictement rien
donc
ça c'est votre métier si vous me si vous
le prenez comme ça donc je
le redis moi je suis là pour vous faire
part de faits physiques l'effet physique
c'est qu'on va en avoir moins et que
avec moins on aura moins de voitures
alors après on peut s'organiser encore
une fois en faisant en sorte que ce soit
pas un drame où on peut ne rien faire et
si on ne fait rien à ce moment ça sera
un drame c'est ça qui va se passer en
fait c'est à dire que les au fur et à
mesure que on sera privé il y a des gens
qui vont être sortis du jeu sans avoir
vu le couvenir à l'avance c'est
exactement ça qui va se passer
si on veut s'organiser pour que ce soit
un drame ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
développe dans ce pays des transports en
commun pas nécessairement des transports
lourds de reste il faut faire aussi des
bus et des autocars il faut faire du
covoiturage il faut faire des modes
actifs alors qu'ils sont
particulièrement pertinents en ville et
en périphérie de ville danse c'est
évidemment beaucoup moins facile de se
balader à vélo sur 30 bornes quand on
est loin de tout
pardon
voilà
oui mais il y a plein d'endroits où on
n'est pas loin tout donc il y a plein
d'endroits où on peut quand même
s'organiser pour faire autrement et
il va falloir également s'occuper du
transport des marchandises et là c'est
exactement pareil il y a une partie du
fret qu'on peut électrifier sur
autoroute ou sur grand axe en hybridant
les camions et en les électrifiant il y
a une partie du fret qu'on peut basculer
sur le ferroviaire il y a une partie du
fret qu'il faut arrêter de déplacer je
pense pas aujourd'hui que si aujourd'hui
on arrêtait les livraisons sous 24
heures par un Gafa que je nommerai pas
je sais pas si la population suiciderait
pas complètement persuadé donc il y a un
certain nombre de choses on peut tout
simplement y renoncer sans que ce soit
dramatique ce qui va être ennuyeux c'est
pour les gens qui travaillent donc en
fait si on doit renoncer à une activité
la vraie question c'est pas tant le
drame pour le consommateur parce qu'il y
a un certain nombre de choses pour
lequel je pense qu'on y arrivera encore
à peu près c'est le drame pour les gens
qui travaillent donc en fait il faut
planifier ce genre de truc et il faut se
le faire avec un préavis suffisant pour
que les gens puissent trouver quelque
chose qui les intéresse ailleurs en ce
qui concerne le transport aérien le
transport aérien est né avec le pétrole
et Morat avec le pétrole là quand on
regarde les alternatives technologiques
il y en a pas une qui est à de façon
raisonnable si on devait je vais juste
vous donner un exemple sur les
agro-carburants le pétrole aujourd'hui
consomme 8% du pétrole mondial l'avion
pardon consomme 8% du pétrole mondial
si je transforme est en agrocarburant
les quatre premières cultures végétales
dans le monde qui sont le maïs le riz le
blé et le soja intégralement en
agrocarburant intégralement un
agrocarburant
j'aurais en gros un quart du pétrole
mondial c'est-à-dire que j'aurais trois
fois ce que consomme l'aérien
donc on oublie les agrocarburants pour
promener des riches en avion
on oublie quoi donc le donc une partie
du transport aérien va se contracter
voilà c'est on va faire avec mais c'est
pas nécessairement un drame voilà on
fera autrement et ces choses là encore
une fois moins on les anticipe
et plus ça sera désagréable donc la
technologie elle va nous permettre
d'amortir un certain nombre de
d'évolution elle va nous permettre de
trouver d'autres choses un vélo
électrique c'est un objet technologique
c'est un objet technologique vous avez
aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'équipementiers en France qui ont
commencé à se mettre à des pièces pour
les vélos électriques si on passe de
voiture importée à des vélos électriques
fabriqués en France on peut à la fois
avoir de la sobriété dans les
déplacements et gagner en emploi
en France donc il faut pas voir
nécessairement le changement de mode de
déplacement comme quelque chose qui est
nécessairement dramatique à chaque fois
il y a des choses intéressantes et des
choses qui sont moins et il faut essayer
de faire le tri de telle sorte que
l'option soit la plus intéressante
possible mais de toute façon les limites
de l'exercice je le redis c'est que du
pétrole on va en avoir de moins en moins
et que c'est un truc qui est tellement
extraordinaire
en terme physique j'ai envie de dire que
les options pour le remplacer on en aura
pas à l'échelle voilà c'est comme ça
mais encore une fois je suis pas sûr que
ce soit très grave si on s'organise bien
pardon j'ai pas couvert les bâtiments
les bâtiments il faut remplacer les
chaudières à fioul par des pompes à
chaleur en ayant isolé les bâtiments
voilà et à ce moment on tombe sur des
problèmes pratiques qui sont avoir
suffisamment d'artisans avoir
suffisamment de pompageurs fabriqués en
France et avoir une production
électrique suffisante voilà c'est on
tombe sur les problèmes pratiques de
cette nature
alors ce que je vous propose on va
essayer de prendre des séries de trois
questions parce que sinon on arrive pas
à tenir le le timing et je reprends
l'ordre des groupes donc Madame manier
millefort
pendant 6 mois
merci monsieur le Président pas
d'inquiétude merci Monsieur Jean-Côme
ici alors moi j'ai une question sur les
besoins de chaleur en France ça
représente je crois 50% à peu près de
l'énergie qu'on consomme en France
l'énergie finale pourquoi est-ce que les
sujets des NR thermique sont si mal
investis en France vous avez évoqué le
prisme électrique mais enfin il y a
peut-être pas que ça donc pourquoi
est-ce que ça bloque autant deuxième
question
sur les l'évolution des consommations
énergétiques on a tendance à voir que
plus on augmente la production plus on
augmente les consommations est-ce qu'à
un moment donné il est possible de
revenir en arrière sur un certain nombre
de technologie inflationniste
énergétique pour retrouver
finalement des des consommations qui
pour répondre à peu près au même usages
consomment d'énergie on voit par exemple
les véhicules ils viennent de plus en
plus gros de plus en plus important
finalement ils servent le même usage
quand ils sont finalement plus petits
moins moins lourd et ils font le même
service rendu donc est-ce qu'on peut
revenir aux usages pour poser la
question du besoin énergétique en France
et du coup poser la question de la
sobriété de cet angle là et ma dernière
question c'est vous avez parlé du
consensus qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
créer dans la population sur une
stratégie énergétique globale qui
dépasserait les alternances politiques
mais en l'occurrence
les grandes oppositions de 10 sensus
qu'on a pu avoir c'était celle des ENR
et du nucléaire pendant longtemps et
pour le coup vous y avez un peu
contribué à créer du dissensus donc
comment est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on dépasse
ce dissensus et est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez réglé vos dissensus avec les
MNR
alors Monsieur pardon on va prendre
plusieurs questions monsieur Lenet
alors
il y avait la chaleur
sobriété et le consensus
alors attendez on va vous trouver ça
du coup monsieur monsieur lainet
merci monsieur le Président j'attendais
que monsieur jean-clauvici est terminé
parce que j'ai un certain nombre de
questions
merci Merci à VOUS déjà pour l'exposé
les premières réponses aux questions je
partage avec vous des objectifs assez
ambitieux de sobriété je crois qu'on
s'en sortira pas si on fixe pas des
objectifs et si on effectivement on
n'arrive pas à les discuter avec les
gens la sobriété doit faire aussi
l'objet de consensus dans la population
bon à certains nombre de questions assez
précises sur le nucléaire et sur les
renouvelables pour finir sur le
nucléaire on a le parc nucléaire
actuellement confronté au problème des
corrosion sont contraintes est-ce que
vous avez des indications techniques sur
le sujet la possibilité de les surmonter
sur les EPR alors vous vous avez parlé
des des centrales de 4e génération mais
actuellement ce qui est en projet c'est
les EPR 2 on a le problème de
Flamanville qui est toujours pas mis en
service et qui doit être mis en service
en 2023 mais je sais plus quel est le
terme mais de manière en mode dégradée
voilà et sur les EPR 2 ailleurs dans le
monde à tihan par exemple on a entendu
parler des SMS est-ce qu'elle est votre
avis là-dessus il me semble que le
nucléaire pose aussi un problème de
délai parce que entre le moment où on
prend la décision ensuite la
construction en fait est-ce que c'est
vraiment raisonnable de Paris et
là-dessus pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique question
suivante c'est vous avez évoqué le
problème de sécheresse et du déficit
d'eau et du réchauffement de l'eau c'est
c'est un souci pour refroidir les
réacteurs quel est votre avis là-dessus
la question du coût du nucléaire aussi
parce que je pense qu'il est pas à
l'heure actuelle il est pas payé à son à
son prix réel EDF et endetté à hauteur
de 60 milliards si on investit dans le
nucléaire est-ce qu'il va rester de
l'argent pour investir dans dans les EnR
7e question sur la question des déchets
nucléaires qui est quand même pas une
petite question qu'on peut balayer d'un
revers de main et pour terminer puisque
il y a quand même une un sujet qui est
le pilotable
dans les énergies renouvelables on a le
biogaz et on a l'hydrogène alors
l'hydrogène qu'il faut d'abord produire
effectivement avec de l'électricité mais
voilà quel est votre avis là-dessus
merci
du coup vu la masse de questions on va
vous laisser répondre puis on reprendra
le cycle des questions après il y a un
plateau repas qui est prévu dans le
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on parle peu de
la chaleur er dans ce pays je vais
tenter une hypothèse
mon hypothèse elle est liée au Grenelle
au moment où a eu lieu le Grenelle de
l'environnement Sarkozy avait dit on ne
parlera pas de nucléaire
du coup les associations
anti-nucléaires n'ont pas parlé
nucléaire mais quand elles ont parlé de
renouvelables elles ont essentiellement
parlé de renouvelables électriques
puisque quand on est tenté nucléaire on
est essentiellement intéressé par les
renouvelables électriques et donc je il
y a eu un gros accent qui a été mis
dessus à l'époque et le sujet était pas
tant climat puisque remplacer une
énergie bas carbone par une autre
énergie bas carbone ça change pas grand
chose du point de vue du climat à ce
moment l'accent était sans le dire mais
quand même une motivation anti-nucléaire
donc je moi j'ai envie de le j'ai envie
de le et ça s'inscrit dans une
opposition du reste ça sera votre
troisième question qui est plus ancienne
et qui était aussi ma remarque tout à
l'heure sur le débat public en disant
que l'opposition pour enfin le nucléaire
et l'élément pivot en général des débats
publics sur l'énergie beaucoup plus que
les hydrocarbures et donc ça a beaucoup
structuré y compris le développement des
eurs pour moi ça c'est ça vient ça vient
de ça
encore aujourd'hui alors je sais pas bon
les derniers informations que j'avais
daté de 2018 ou 2019 en 2018 ou 2019
vous aviez quand même plus de deux tiers
des Français qui pensaient que le
nucléaire contribue significativement
aux émissions gaz à effet de serre et à
mon avis c'est une conséquence directe
de ce débat et du fait que on a très
longtemps opposé ENR au nucléaire
au lieu de mettre ça dans une même
famille d'énergie bas carbone ce qui
aura évidemment changé différemment sur
lesquels on peut être d'accord ou pas
d'accord sur la répartition c'est un
autre sujet ce qui aurait changé la
perception du public
c'est alors là pour le coup c'est très
différent dans d'autres pays européens
il y a beaucoup de d'autres pays
européens mais en général quand la
chaleur renouvelable a fait l'objet de
politique de promotion ancienne c'est
que le pays avait par ailleurs un
potentiel important donc dans les pays
du Nord qui ont des gisements forestiers
très importants rapportés à la
population la chaleur renouvelable fait
l'objet de défauts depuis longtemps
quand vous êtes en Islande qui a la pop
et qui est un peu plus peuplé que
Boulogne-Billancourt mais pas beaucoup
et que vous avez le potentiel
géothermique que vous avez c'est
pareil il y a une promotion de la
chaleur renouvelable qui est faite
depuis longtemps il y a probablement
aussi peut-être qu'il y a aussi en
France cet élément qui a joué
c'est-à-dire que la chaleur renouvelable
elle avait pas un potentiel très
important quand elle avait un potentiel
important dans certaines régions de
France pense en particulier aux dames à
ce moment elle a fait l'objet d'une
promotion aussi puisque les chauffe-eau
solaires sont beaucoup sont
raisonnablement répandues dans les
territoires d'outre-mer
comment est-ce que on fait en sorte de
limiter les usages dans le décidant
rien ne nous empêche en théorie de
militer en enfin à l'Europe puisque
maintenant c'est l'Europe qui a la
compétence pour que on limite le poids
des véhicules neufs vendus
il y a pas de limite physique à ça il y
a juste une affaire de volonté
il faut bien voir que quand on augmente
les usages en fait ça augmente
l'activité économique sous-jacente et
quand on a comme prisme de lecture
premier quoi qu'on fasse le prisme
économique en fait on va assez rarement
chercher à limiter les usages même quand
il s'agit de fumer quand il s'agit de
manger et de boire trop sucré ou trop
gras etc on va pas limiter les usages on
en fait de la pub donc en fait dès lors
qu'on prend les activités sous l'angle
économique
il y a un mécanisme qui se met en route
naturellement qui est de pousser à
l'inflation des usages parce que c'est
ça qui pousse à l'inflation de
l'activité
donc ça veut dire que si on veut en
sortir
ça renvoie au débat qu'on a eu tout à
l'heure il faut qu'on accepte de changer
la hiérarchie des indicateurs
ce qui est pas simple mais ça passera
par là
est-ce que je suis sorti du dissensus
j'ai toujours la même opinion en ce qui
concerne la pertinence de remplacer du
nucléaire par des ENR ça j'ai toujours
dit que c'était un truc qui servait à
rien et je continue à penser que ça sert
à rien
après délibérément il vient de
délibérément je pense que ça sert à rien
et que ça a été une perte de temps et
d'argent maintenant est-ce que dans le
cas dans lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui
c'est stupide de faire des ENR non et ça
dépend lesquels et ça dépend pourquoi
faire donc je continue à penser qu'il
faut raisonner de manière pragmatique et
différenciée et qu'il ne faut pas ni
nucléaire ni NR de tous les brevets de
vertus encore une fois toutes les
énergies ont des avantages et des
inconvénients et ce que j'espère c'est
de il me semble que la bonne situation
est celle dans laquelle on juge sur
pièces
c'est évidemment pas la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes le plus souvent
mais c'est vers ça qu'il faut essayer de
tendre
alors
est-ce que j'ai des informations sur la
corrosion sous contrainte oui il y a des
informations publiques il y a les WWW
qui a fait une audition à l'OPEX pas
plus tard qu'il y a quelques jours dans
laquelle il a repris il a fait quelque
chose d'assez complet je sais pas si
vous l'avez vu passer bah je voulais
aller voir parce que c'est assez complet
et en particulier
les indications il fournit un certain
nombre d'indications techniques
sur le sur la chose
qu'est-ce que je pense de l'EPR 2 et des
SMS alors je pense que l'EPR était un
truc qui était trop compliqué parce que
on a cherché à faire plaisir à la fois
aux Français et aux Allemands parce que
je vous rappelle que c'est un réacteur
de conception
franco-allemande
depuis l'origine la SN n'a jamais eu à
sa charge je dis pas qu'il faut qu'elle
l'aime mais je rappelle juste n'a jamais
eu à sa charge de faire un arbitrage
coup bénéfice sur les mesures de sûreté
qu'elle est chargée de mettre en œuvre
dit autrement son seul prisme de lecture
c'est il faut que ce soit sûr mais si le
fait que ce soit trop sûr engendre un
risque de défaut d'approvisionnement qui
lui-même pourrait avoir des conséquences
extrêmement délétères c'est hors de son
mandat
c'est hors de son champ
or il me semble que on ne pourra pas
faire l'économie dans un monde qui va
lui-même être en économie de moyens de
se poser ce genre de questions il me
semble qu'à l'avenir on va
nécessairement être obligé de se poser
la question de savoir jusqu'où est-ce
qu'on accepte de ne pas disposer à temps
mais c'est vrai pour n'importe quoi
c'est aussi vrai pour les éoliennes qui
emmerdent un certain nombre de gens et
pour lesquels on se dit bah il nous en
Kikine on va quand même en faire parce
que c'est nécessaire donc c'est vrai
d'une façon plus large on va
nécessairement être obligé de revoir
l'arbitrage avantage inconvénient à
l'eau d'un monde dans lequel on est un
peu dans une course contre la montre et
dans lequel on va être en économie
forcée de moyens de façon croissante de
façon croissante il va c'est dans ce
cadre là qui va falloir raisonner ce qui
est un cadre évidemment beaucoup moins
confortable que le cadre dans lequel on
raisonnait jusqu'à maintenant qui est un
cadre dans lequel on se dit on a le
temps et on a par ailleurs pas d'effet
d'éviction puisque dans un monde en
croissance et où on n'est pas en pénurie
de moyens on peut courir plein de livres
à la fois dans un monde dans lequel on
n'est pas en crois si on court le
mauvais c'est qu'on court pas le bon et
là on a un effet d'éviction dont on paye
le prix directement
donc dans ce monde là est-ce que il faut
faire un nucléaire aussi sur entre
guillemets ou exactement aussi complexe
plutôt que sur que celui qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est pas évident est-ce
qu'il faut faire que des EPR 2 pour
remplacer le parc actuel je ne le crois
pas personne allemand
j'ai envie de dire le la solution qui
aurait ma préférence c'est de mettre le
paquet sur le développement de la
quatrième génération parce que je pense
que aujourd'hui on est à 15 ans de
pouvoir disposer si on se met entre
guillemets en économie de guerre qui est
un terme que j'utilise parfois
on est à 15 ans de pouvoir disposer de
modèles déployables
et à ce moment on fait la jonction avec
des EPR le temps de pouvoir commencer à
déployer de la quatrième génération
mais on en fait pas plus que ça voilà
c'est pas une option aujourd'hui qui est
sur la table
et dans l'intervalle c'est évident que
aujourd'hui la seule option qui reste
donc aux Français de décider quelque
part si on veut plus d'électricité même
si elle est pas pilotable c'est de
rajouter des moyens VNR dans les 10 à 15
ans qui viennent il y a pas il y a rien
d'autre à faire parce que ça va quand
même plus vite de rajouter une éolienne
que de rajouter un réacteur ce qui avec
les EnR la difficulté dans le système
donc elle est pas dans l'objet faire une
éolienne c'est pas compliqué par contre
faire un système qui repose
majoritairement sur des sources non
pilotables ça c'est tellement complexe
que personnellement je pense que on va
avoir beaucoup de mal à y arriver
mais on peut en rajouter un peu ça c'est
clair et par ailleurs il y a un scénario
que j'ai trouvé assez malin qui a été
publié il y a pas très longtemps par une
association qui s'appelle voie du
nucléaire
dans lequel la proposition c'est de
construire dans les décennies qui
viennent à la fois tant qu'on n'est pas
capable de faire la jonction avec du
nucléaire de quatrième génération et du
nucléaire de 3e pour lui-même faire la
jonction c'est de développer des moyens
enr
et des steps de construire des steps en
France voilà je trouve que c'est ça se
regarde il faut regarder ça d'un peu
près je trouve que c'est pas
il y a quelque chose de séduisant dans
cette approche alors je n'ai pas regardé
je l'ai pas regardé sur toutes les
coutures je n'ai pas etc mais je trouve
que c'est quelque chose qui est pas
inintéressant et ce que disent alors ça
ça vous plaira peut-être moins mais ce
que dit c'est une fois que on est
capable de déployer du nucléaire de 4e
génération et qu'on retombe sur des
choses qui sont pilotables compactes etc
à ce moment les éoliennes qu'on a
construit une fois bon on l'a construit
pas une deuxième c'est à dire qu'une
fois qu'on a la plus besoin au bout de
30 ans on les on les déconstruit puis on
s'arrête là
ça se regarde je trouve que c'est pas
inintéressant comme
comme scénario
qu'est-ce que je pense des SMS si c'est
small ça sera small donc je pense que
c'est pas quelque chose qui va
significativement changer la donne
en fait ça peut être très intéressant
pour les régions insulaires
qui aujourd'hui dépendent de
l'électricité au fioul ou de
l'électricité au charbon donc ça peut
être intéressant pour eux
alors après il y avait tout un tas de
trucs sur le nucléaire allez les délais
bon je pense que j'ai répondu voilà
sécheresse c'est un problème de
production c'est pas un problème de
sûreté en fait comme vous le savez
probablement quand on met un réacteur à
l'arrêt parce que pour Dieu c'est quelle
raison vous avez besoin pour le
maintenir en conditions froides d'un
millième de l'eau dont vous avez besoin
en fonctionnement normal donc si jamais
vous avez plus assez d'eau bah le risque
que vous courez c'est le défaut de
production mais vous courrez pas un
risque de pour la sûreté alors le risque
en défaut de production il existe pour
tous les modes qui dépendent de l'eau
donc il existe pour les centrales
nucléaires il existe pour les centrales
thermiques alors accessoirement on en
veut plus non plus il existe aussi pour
l'hydroélectricité j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure
voilà une anecdote ridicule une anecdote
marrante je sais pas si vous le savez
mais la plus grosse centrale nucléaire
américaine fonctionne sans mer et sans
rivière elle fonctionne avec les eaux
usées d'une ville donc ce qui lui sert
de source froide c'est les eaux usées
d'une ville
la question du coup
alors la question du coût du nucléaire
et pour moi essentiellement une une
question de cadre de marché
vous savez vous avez probablement
entendu parler du coût du mégawattheure
de la centrale de inclipoint qui va
sortir un peu plus de 100 livres
c'est-à-dire quelque chose entre 100 et
150 euros de mémoire
j'ai fait un petit calcul et en fait si
le financement de cette centrale avait
été fait avec de l'argent disponible à
2% par an et non pas avec de l'argent
disponible à 10% par an comme c'est le
cas dans le cadre de marché aujourd'hui
ou les acteurs prennent leur risque etc
la même centrale aurait produit des
mégawatt-heure aux alentours de 50 euros
donc en fait le vrai sujet du coût du
nucléaire pour moi c'est les structures
de financement et la structure de
financement dépend essentiellement du
fait que ça soit mis dans un cadre
public ou pas donc je vais le dire
autrement le nucléaire pour moi n'a rien
à faire dans un cas de privé c'est pas
essence une activité qui est régalienne
qui relève de l'État et qui doit accéder
à des financements qui sont ceux de
l'État
mais
j'ai le même raisonnement pour les EnR
je fais partie des gens qui considèrent
que d'avoir fourni des produits
financiers à 15% de rendement sur
capitaux investi sur les premiers
panneaux solaires c'était quelque chose
qui n'aurait jamais dû exister
la question des déchets alors c'est une
question
qui est très important dans le débat
public c'est à dire quand on regarde de
quoi les gens ont peur
quand il s'agit du nucléaire les déchets
c'est quelque chose qui arrive assez
haut dans l'ordre de priorité et alors
c'est quelque chose qui
[Musique]
pour moi
n'est pas du tout raccord avec la
hiérarchie des nuisances quand on
regarde tout ce qu'on bazarde dans
l'environnement c'est à dire que quand
on regarde tout ce qu'on bazarde dans
l'environnement je le CO2 les
phytosanitaires les particules fines etc
en fait les déchets nucléaires pour moi
j'aurais peut-être faire sauter en l'air
quelques personnes dans cette salle mais
c'est vraiment du deuxième ordre enfin
c'est c'est tout petit il y en a
quelques-uns alors évidemment c'est des
franges saloperies mais il y en a pas
beaucoup mais c'est confiné etc et deux
très loin l'option préférentielle c'est
de les mettre dans un trou et les
oublier
c'est exactement ce que les Suédois ont
décidé de faire je considère que le
retraitement est une bonne idée parce
que ça permet de concentrer le volume
qui a stocké derrière de façon très
importante
et puis ça permet de récupérer
un certain nombre de choses qui sont
récupérables dans les assemblages usées
par contre il me semble que le et la
réversibilité du stockage je sais qu'il
y a des gens qui tiennent beaucoup
personnellement ça me semble pas crucial
il y a un stockage non réversible qui
s'est fait de façon tout à fait naturel
il y a 2 milliards d'années dans une
mine d'uranium au Gabon à Outlook ou des
réacteurs sont apparus spontanément
il y a le détail dans quelques-uns de
mes ouvrages si ça je peux vous donnerai
les références à vous amuse et donc les
déchets qui ont été produits à l'époque
c'est-à-dire des produits de fission qui
ont été produit à l'époque en fait ont
très peu migré par rapport à l'endroit
où ils ont été formés et c'était il y a
2 milliards d'années donc je suis pas du
tout inquiet quand on fait que si on les
met dans une poussée dans une couche
géologique profonde on est capable de
mettre du pétrole et du gaz sous
pression qui va rester là pendant des
millions d'années et pourtant c'est
fluide et c'est à haute pression donc
dans une couche géologique appropriée on
peut très bien mettre quelque chose de
solide c'est-à-dire des colis vitrifiés
et pas être très inquiets sur le fait
que tel Zébulon ça va nous sauter la
figure
50 ans derrière dernière chose qu'il
faut savoir sur les déchets c'est que
les produits de fission au bout de
quelques siècles sont revenus au niveau
de radioactivité de l'uranium initial
au bout de quelques siècles oui enfin
c'est moins que Notre-Dame bon
qui est à l'air libre
qui est à l'air libre qui est donc qui
est beaucoup plus agressé qui est
beaucoup voilà donc c'est non mais c'est
dire quelques voilà
c'est pour dire souvent le chiffre de
100000 ans est mis en avant en fait il
faut voir que la partie la plus
radiotoxique de ce qu'on produit ça vit
pas du tout cette durée là c'est
beaucoup plus court
enfin qu'est-ce que je pense du biogaz
et de l'hydrogène alors le biogaz c'est
quelque chose qui de mon point de vue
est intéressant pour des usages de niche
alors le biogaz est une est une énergie
dérivée de la biomasse donc faire ce
qu'on fait les Allemands c'est-à-dire
faire des cultures dédiées pour faire
des grandes quantités de biogaz et
quelque chose qui me paraît pas du tout
pertinent
par contre faire du biogaz avec des
déchets agricoles ou avec des
couvertures intermédiaires et ensuite
s'en servir prioritairement pour
remplacer les combustibles fossiles de
la mécanisation agricole ça c'est
quelque chose qui me paraît tout à fait
pertinent dans le plan de transformation
de l'économie française on propose
déconstruire le réseau de gaz en France
puisqu'on propose de se passer de gaz
tout court qui était essentiellement
fossile aujourd'hui donc du coup
l'injection dans le réseau devient un
peu moins intéressantes et enfin la
production électrique elle peut
éventuellement être intéressante à
partir du moment où on s'en sert pour
remplacer le gaz dans les usages d'hyper
fin de dans les turbines quoi dans des
usages d'hyperpointes mais à ce moment
c'est plus tellement le même genre
d'installation parce qu'il faut des
grosses installations
histoire d'avoir des quantités de gaz
qui sont pas complètement ridicules
l'hydrogène pour stocker de la
production électrique intermittente le
rendement de chaîne est extrêmement
mauvais il est de l'ordre du car c'est à
dire que vous perdez 75% de l'énergie
électrique initiale dans le donc il vaut
mieux si on veut absolument stocker de
l'électricité
faire des stations de pompage voilà
reste à convaincre quelques habitants de
Savoie que on va noyer les vallées avec
l'eau du lac Léman
[Musique]
merci bien on reprend une le tour des
groupes monsieur bolo
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur jean-clauvici je voudrais
revenir sur deux points que vous avez
évoqué avec nous le premier c'est
l'accès aux métaux qui conditionne notre
indépendance énergétique et ensuite le
deuxième point c'est la disponibilité
des ressources qui est un facteur
limitant d'une économie mais une
économie ça produit aussi des déchets ou
des objets en fin de vie qui ont une
valeur selon le principe de l'économie
circulaire nous évoquait une énergie
plus importante nécessaire pour extraire
des métaux à la teneur réduite dans les
mines cette même quantité d'énergie pour
être utilisée pour recycler les métaux
qui se prêtent d'ailleurs plutôt bien au
recyclage donc la question est très
simple quel est votre analyse de
l'économie circulaire
alors madame matistel
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup pour toutes les réponses
fournies que vous avez apportées
d'ailleurs ça nous laisse assez peu de
questions maintenant
simplement revenir sur l'objet de notre
commission d'enquête c'est analyser
l'éventuelle perte de souveraineté ou
d'indépendance énergétique de la France
du coup vous nous expliquez comme
beaucoup d'autres qu'elle n'a jamais été
atteinte et
pour se servir des erreurs qu'auraient
pu être faites par le passé on a besoin
de de cette analyse et je crois que
c'est véritablement l'objet de notre de
notre commission d'enquête vous nous
avez expliqué que sur toutes les
énergies finalement l'indépendance la
souveraineté est inatteignable parce
qu'on dépend de toute façon d'un
matériau que ce soit pour l'éolien pour
les pompes à chaleur pour le pétrole
pour l'énergie nucléaire etc sur la
question de hydro il y a effectivement
le stress hydrique mais on a un certain
nombre d'études qui nous dit quand même
que la courbe de pluviométrie peut-être
très
accentué enfin très oui fluctuante mais
quand même les quantités peuvent être là
et l'hydroélectricité à cette capacité
de stockage et sa flexibilité qui peut
peut-être lui permettre d'avoir une
sortie alors je parle de la grosse
hydroélectricité et pas de la petite
dont vous avez parlé ou de la micro et
vous évoquez d'ailleurs la question des
steps qui dont certains nombre de
projets sont sur la table pas que dans
la vallée de la Savoie mais bien
ailleurs est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y
a une acceptabilité suffisante pour
aujourd'hui voir arriver une step dans
une vallée auquel qu'elle soit
et ses avantages de STEP c'est quand
même à la fois la flexibi et la question
de la pointe
que l'on évoquait tout à l'heure sur le
nucléaire bon vous avez largement
répondu à mon collègue donc je ne vais
pas y revenir et j'avais une deuxième
question qui était sur
sur sur
ben voilà je vais les perdue mais ça me
reviendra probablement en tout cas sur
sur cette question ah oui la dernière
question c'était finalement si on écoute
vos propos on serait plutôt dans la
situation où il faut se poser la
question plutôt de savoir quelle est
l'énergie qu'il faut produire comment on
réorganise notre société pour infiner ce
passer d'un certain nombre de
productions qu'on aura de toute façon
plus dans les années qui viennent donc
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on est à ce
stade de conscience des populations et
du monde politique évidemment
dans cette orientation là
alors on va encore prendre les questions
de Monsieur Alfandari et de Madame
lernos comme Monsieur Jean vaucovici
note tout
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
Monsieur Jean-Côme ici merci de vos
propos vous avez déjà répondu à une
large partie de ce que je voulais vous
demander mais bon sur le principe sur
l'hypothèse de base de faire moins et de
faire avec ce qu'on a déjà prélevé c'est
certain je dois avouer que j'aime bien
votre votre point sur la différence
entre l'indépendance et le confort il y
a probablement peut-être plus de
souveraineté du côté du confort que
l'indépendance qui est peut-être assez
illusoire sauf si on cherche des guerres
bon dans vos travaux vous l'avez
clairement dit on a à peu près plus
qu'une seule cartouche à tirer on avait
à 30 ans pour agir au niveau mondial
et ce qui est extrêmement difficile
c'est
c'est le phasage c'est très clairement
c'est d'arriver à voir la différence
entre ce qui est mature entre ce qui
sera est intéressant et deviendra
maturat à terme et la manière dont on
déploie l'ensemble de ces solutions à
travers le temps
typiquement c'est ce que vous disiez sur
le réacteur de quatrième génération
j'étais avec des gens du nucléaire qui
me disaient 50 ans pour la 4e vous dites
si on décide et qu'on y met la volonté
15 ans donc voilà il y a la question de
combien de réacteurs on déploie quelle
génération en déploie pour quelle
jonction
il y a après dans vos travaux il y a je
sais qu'il y a des il y a des points un
peu
qui sont mis un peu de côté qui est
clairement l'identification de la
ressource par exemple on parlait des
déchets juste avant et d'économie
circulaire il y a des procédés de
gazéification sur une partie de choses
qui ne sont plus traitables mais en même
temps si on veut de diminuer les
produits pétroliers si on est sur
d'autres types de plastique est-ce qu'il
y a des plastiques qui sont circulaires
sur lequel on va trouver le même
potentiel hydrogène ou pas il y a le
problème donc des dimensions industriels
de ce qu'on va faire et puis toute la
question du programme
par exemple j'ai visité une société qui
fait de l'impression 3D et qui
aujourd'hui fait des faits des pièces
qui sont beaucoup moins lourdes
notamment pour le transport ferroviaire
sans perdre de matière il y a des gains
probablement à trouver par là et pareil
dans vos travaux vous vous l'esquissez
mais on prend pas trop en compte la
question de l'aménagement du territoire
dans les modes de vie qu'on va changer
il y a bien sûr des
usages comme marjols le disait qu'on
pourrait abandonner ou mais il y a aussi
la question de comment on occupe le
territoire et comment on vit dessus et
ça c'est c'est extrêmement difficile à
prendre en compte
et puis enfin je vais être un peu je
provoque pour tous les blancs on voit
bien que
ceux qui gagneront demain sont pas
forcément
ce qui perdront aujourd'hui qui a
l'accompagnement de ça et moi ça me pose
la question du salaire universel par
exemple
tu as l'air universelle dividende
universel enfin ce que
quel que soit le nom en tout cas quelque
chose ou qui qui vient clairement
accompagner les gens dans cette mutation
profonde qui va toucher nos systèmes
économiques nos systèmes sociaux nos
systèmes de production de déplacement et
d'habitat
oui merci
plusieurs questions et plusieurs
réactions aussi tout d'abord le chiffre
project et les travaux que vous avez
menés ont éclairé un certain nombre de
points importants notamment sur la
sobriété sur la de prendre de manière
globale les problématiques et vos propos
introductifs notamment sur avoir
l'économie comme donner sortante et non
pas entrante en fonction des ressources
dont on dispose
favorisent la réflexion un peu plus
approfondie et globale plutôt que de se
dire qu'il y a une solution
technologique qui va sauver tout notre
climat et nous préserver du
réchauffement climatique à venir et je
pense que l'accent n'est d'ailleurs pas
assez mis souvent y compris quand on
évoque votre nom souvent ce n'est pas
vos propos ou vos travaux sur la
sobriété la rénovation sur ce que vous
avez eu comme propos et qui sont dans
vos écrits aussi notamment vis-à-vis du
transport aérien ou là il n'y aura pas
de solution technique qui permettra de
continuer à se déplacer sur des longs
courts comme nous le faisons aujourd'hui
mais qu'il y a là dans vos écrits de
manière scientifique technique étayées
le fait qu'il faut envisager une autre
manière de vivre et une autre manière de
partager aussi les ressources qui me
semblent importantes sur lequel il
faudrait à mon sens mettre plus l'accent
je reviendrai sur vous avez évoqué
effectivement la question du consensus
et je pense que vous et votre nom
aujourd'hui évoque pas mal de dissensus
y compris par rapport aux écologistes
puisque
ils comptent dans les dans les travaux
et puis dans les propos que vous avez
tenu y compris sur la responsabilité qui
serait dû à l'accord électoraliste entre
le Parti socialiste et ma formation
politique et Europe écologie des Verts
ça serait là le début du mot des mots et
la perte de souveraineté en tout cas en
matière de nucléaire j'ai envie de dire
que pour le physicien que vous êtes dans
le réchauffement climatique et la lutte
qui nous rassemble toutes et tous en
tout cas dans les solutions qu'on essaye
d'y apporter et d'y trouver on sait très
bien que c'est les 15 prochaines années
qui sont cruciales puisque les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre s'accumulent
aujourd'hui et provoque donc des
réchauffement climatique qui va
s'amplifier or la solution qui semble
trouver la seule solution j'ai envie de
dire qu'ils sont trouvées la vraie grâce
à vos yeux qui est le nucléaire ne
pourra pas se déployer de manière
massive comme vous l'appelez de vos vœux
d'ici les 15 prochaines années
d'ailleurs vous évoquez sur les points
de vue technologiques entre le père
troisième génération 4e génération on ne
sait pas exactement sur quelle
technologie on pourrait s'appuyer pour
lancer d'un point de vue massif vous
dites vous-même que c'est assez
utopique d'un point de vue de
réalisation parce que tout n'est pas
aligné dans ce sens là et donc j'ai
quand même une interrogation
réelle de savoir quand vous faites tous
ces travaux et aligner tous ces travaux
on voit bien que la fermeture de
Fessenheim aurait pu largement être
compensée si l'État français avait
réellement investi dans les énergies
renouvelables avec tenu ses objectifs et
compris en matière de sobriété que ça
soit dans les transports ou dans tous
les potentiels j'ai envie de dire non
activé dans la rénovation énergétique et
thermique on voit que ça serait dix fois
supérieur à ce que était la production
de Fessenheim et d'ailleurs les
responsables à ce moment-là que ça soit
RTE ou y compris au sein d'EDF avec fu
kushima qui est intervenu les
investissements étaient trop élevés dans
la sécurisation de la centrale de
Fessenheim pardon pour pouvoir la
maintenir ouverte et donc c'est là une
enfin j'ai une réelle interrogation
puisque tout semble conjugué pour vous
vers le nucléaire or il me semble que si
vous prenez l'effet là où on en est les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
vaut aujourd'hui éviter
ça ne paraît pas le plus logique y
compris en termes d'ingénierie
d'utilisation de métaux d'utilisation
d'importation parce qu'il faut aussi
importer l'uranium et je voudrais
revenir aussi puisque vous avez et vous
êtes le premier qui répond à la question
ce que nous avons posé la question de
nombreuses reprises sur la question du
réchauffement climatique et de la
sécheresse c'est à dire que tout les
centrales nucléaires sont construits à
proximité de cours d'eau on voit que cet
été en dehors des problèmes de corrosion
sous contrainte et du vieillissement du
parc actuel on voit que cet été on a
autorisé des dérogations aux droits pour
pouvoir rejeter de l'eau plus chaude
dans nos fleuves et qu'on va manquer de
plus en plus d'eau et je ne trouve pas
très sérieux alors que vos propos sont
très étayés et factuels de dire que on
va utiliser l'eau des égouts qui par
ailleurs peut être relativement plus
chaude pour refroidir les réacteurs
nucléaires et puis on parle dans le
projet de loi d'accélération sur le
nucléaire et également de déroger aux
droits littoral notamment pour
construire des nouveaux réacteurs le
long des côtes or on voit là aussi que
le réchauffement climatique
va engendrer une hausse du niveau de la
mer et donc j'ai une vraie interrogation
sur il y a un vrai regret j'ai envie de
dire c'est à dire que autant une grande
partie de vos travaux illustre et sont
importants et contribuent à l'évolution
des consciences et des actes y compris
dans le secteur privé parce qu'on ne
pourra pas
diminuer nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre sans accompagner et avoir le
secteur privé avec nous pour
s'interroger sur ce qu'on produit
pourquoi on le produit pour autant la
solution monomaniaque sur le nucléaire
me semble pour le coup créer du
dissensus alors qu'il nous faudrait un
consensus et pour le coup une vraie arme
de guerre pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique qui va plus sur
la sobriété la rénovation et les
énergies renouvelables et il y a des
scénarios qui comprennent tout cela et
qui disent aussi que c'est tout à fait
faisable vous faites le choix dans
choisir un autre mais voilà c'est ça mon
interrogation principale
la question est assez simple c'est à
dire que vous la question vous misez y
compris en termes de matériaux
disponibles du cuivre etc vous dites les
énergies renouvelables sont trop
gourmandes pour cela et ne produisent
pas assez d'électrons vous dites qu'il y
a que le nucléaire qui peut faire ça or
vous hésitez vous-même entre les
différentes générations et vous dites
que les unr sont là que pour faire la
jonction or qu'est-ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui contre le réchauffement
climatique d'ici que le fait qu'on
puisse de manière hypothétique
construire de nouvelles nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires c'est-à-dire que
même vous vous n'avez pas d'informations
ou de propositions fiables sur quelle
génération vous avez parlé de l'uranium
235 et 238 et puis sur les propositions
en termes des ressources qui nous sont
dits souvenirs notamment les ressources
en eau pour refroidir les réacteurs pas
non plus donc je ne comprends pas
quelque part malgré la richesse des
travaux et des propos pourquoi vous vous
entêtez sur cette un du nucléaire c'est
ça ma question merci beaucoup Monsieur
Jean-Claude je voulais y répondre je
vous informe qu'avant je prendrai une
dernière série de questions après parce
que là comme ça on a fini le tour des
orateurs de groupe et on fera une
dernière série de questions j'ai noté
trois personnes encore
voilà je vous laisse la parole
alors
où est-ce que j'en étais dans
la première série de questions
concernant les métaux c'est ça c'est ça
alors quand on utilise le terme
d'économie circulaire en fait il y a une
petite méprise les atomes sont
recyclables l'énergie jamais
donc il faut bien voir que d'aller
récupérer des atomes là où ils sont
c'est ça l'économie circulaire j'ai des
atomes j'ai des molécules dans un
plastique un polymère et je vais essayer
de les récupérer pour en refaire un
polymère et bien ça c'est quelque chose
qui va quand même vous demander de
l'énergie
donc l'économie circulaire elle peut
être une solution
partielle ou importante à des questions
de disponibilité en matière en
ressources par contre ça va toujours
même l'économie circulaire avec une mise
en oeuvre enfin avec la disponibilité
d'une source énergétique dans certains
cas de figure l'énergie du recyclage
n'est pas considérablement inférieure à
l'énergie de la production de matières
primaire c'est notamment le cas du
papier c'est un exemple qui est bien
connu parce que des ancré le papier
c'est très énergivore et donc recycler
du papier ça permet assurément d'éviter
de couper des arbres puisque ça permet
d'éviter de
enfin ça permet d'éviter de
s'approvisionner en fibres de bois
Vierge par contre sur le plan
strictement énergétique on gagne pas
énormément alors il y a des métaux qui
se recyclent facilement il y a des
métaux qui se recyclent beaucoup plus
difficiles les métaux qui se recyclent
facilement c'est les métaux qui sont peu
alliés par exemple le cuivre est un
métal qui s'utilise tel que il est
généralement pas allié on ne mélange pas
avec un autre métal ce recycle
extrêmement bien il est extrêmement
fortement recyclé vous avez d'autres
métaux qui s'utilisent en étant alliés
c'est-à-dire que il se trouve dans un
voyage et par exemple le manganèse est
un adjuvant de l'acier et vous n'avez
pas d'usage de manganèse pure enfin très
peu donc pour récupérer du manganèse en
fait il faut récupérer de l'acier
vous avez un certain nombre de petits
métaux qu'on appelle les terres rares
qui sont dans l'électronique par exemple
qui sont dilués à des concentrations qui
sont beaucoup trop faibles pour que ce
soit facile de les récupérer dans les
objets dans lesquels ils sont donc on
peut le faire mais avec des dépenses
énergétiques extrêmement importantes qui
peuvent être éventuellement supérieurs à
la dépense énergétique d'extraction de
la croûte terrestre donc il y a pas de
en fait il y a pas de réponse univoque
unique pardon à faire à la question que
vous posez là aussi il faut regarder en
fonction du métal etc il faut bien voir
que souvent pour les métaux qui valent
un peu cher et qui sont disponibles
quelque part sous forme un peu pur les
opérations de recyclage elles ont déjà
lieu
ça existe déjà par exemple tout ce qui
est chute dans l'usinage en général
c'est des métaux qui sont recyclés c'est
très rare que ces trucs là soient perdus
parce que ça c'est quelque chose qui est
facile à utiliser facile à recycler etc
les carcasses de voiture c'est facile à
recycler vous les collez directement
dans le convertisseur et ça va par
contre je le redis il y a d'autres
métaux c'est plus c'est plus difficile
de les c'est plus difficile de les
récupérer et il y a d'autres ressources
c'est plus difficile de les récupérer
aussi par exemple sur certains
plastiques des polymérisés des
plastiques pour les repolymériser
derrière ça peut être extrêmement
compliqué ça peut ne pas être possible
ça peut être très énergivore quand un
plastique est vieux il peut avoir été un
peu fatigué par le rayonnement
ultraviolet etc donc vous en refaites
pas l'usage initial c'est le fameux
exemple de la fourrure polaire qui est
faite avec des déchets de bouteilles
voilà donc il y a des choses à faire
c'est très difficile de faire une
réponse générale donc il faut regarder
au cas par cas et bien évidemment à
chaque fois qu'on peut gagner quelque
chose il faut le faire
après
il y avait une question sur les steps
c'est ça pourquoi est-ce que on fait pas
plus de STEP et quelle est
l'acceptabilité pour en faire
l'acceptabilité est faible comme pour à
chaque fois que vous avez l'intention de
construire quelque chose quelque part
donc
la réponse un peu plus générale que je
pourrais faire c'est que une des choses
sur lesquelles il faut arriver à se
mettre d'accord mais c'est difficile à
installer dans le débat politique par je
même du débat politique c'est l'idée que
les temps qui viennent vont ne se
prêteront à aucune solution parfaite
et que donc il va falloir accepter de
façon un peu partagée ce qu'on considère
être le plus faible inconvénient
ou l'idée qu'on se fait collectivement
du plus faible inconvénient
et évidemment ça sera toujours au
détriment des gens qui vont être
localement concernés par le plus faible
inconvénient donc si on décide que le
plus faible inconvénient c'est de faire
des steps il y a quand même des gens qui
sont localement là où on va faire la
STEP qui vont pas être d'accord du tout
du reste le droit a prévu depuis très
longtemps que on puisse passer par
dessus la tête de ces gens-là c'est les
procédures d'expropriation toute la
question elle est de savoir
collectivement où est-ce qu'on met le
moins de douleurs pour le plus de
bénéfices pour la collectivité c'est
toujours ça la question sachant qu'à un
moment il y a toujours des gens il va
falloir leur passer par-dessus la tête
mais on a exactement le même problème
avec n'importe quel installation qui
demande de couler du béton quelque part
c'est
on a le problème on a le problème
partout
alors après il y avait tellement de
questions
il
y a j'ai noté plein de trucs
il y avait un sujet sur le progrès il y
avait un sujet sur l'aménagement du
territoire
et comment se passait d'un certain
welcome à installer la sobriété
j'en reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
le fait d'arriver à installer la
sobriété va avec le fait que il y a le
cadre physique dans lequel nous devons
raisonner à partir de maintenant ne nous
laisse plus toutes les options alors il
y a des domaines dans lequel on le sait
depuis longtemps par exemple si je bas
des bras dans cette pièce je vais pas
voler pour autant donc il y a des degrés
de liberté physique qu'on a pas on le
sait depuis longtemps ce qui est
beaucoup plus désagréable c'est de
d'accepter l'idée que des degrés de
physique qu'on a eu par exemple pour
quelques heures de Smic de monter dans
un engin qui va à 800 km/h et qui vous
emmène à 2000 km de là où vous êtes
on ne l'aura plus ça c'est quelque chose
qui est compliqué et ça va
nécessairement avec une notion un mot
que j'ai pas encore prononcé jusqu'à
maintenant qui est le mot de l'équité il
y a eu il y a pas longtemps comme vous
le savez probablement un petit débat sur
la question des jets privés alors quand
vous regardez ce que représente les jets
privés dans les émissions du pays où la
consommation de carburant du pays c'est
pas quelque chose qui est absolument
crucial
par contre c'est très emblématique d'un
luxe ostentatoire qui apparaît comme
insupportable à des gens qui vont devoir
faire des efforts sur des gestes qui
sont unitairement des gestes beaucoup
plus modestes et donc la question de la
sobriété pour moi elle est
fondamentalement associée à la question
1 de la maîtrise de son propre destin
donc ça renvoie à la question qui a été
posée par votre collègue urn tout à
l'heure sur comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour que des gens acceptent
de continuer à avoir l'impression d'être
maître de leur destin alors même qu'il y
a des choses qui physiquement lorsqu'on
plus accessibles donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui est évidemment une question
cruciale et ça va également avec l'idée
d'un arbitrage entre moins de liberté
aujourd'hui pour plus de liberté plus
tard parce que il y a aussi une question
qui a été posée sur la démocratie le
fait de pouvoir continuer du reste par
le même le reste de pouvoir continuer à
vivre en démocratie dans 20 ans
combien est-ce qu'on est prêt à payer
aujourd'hui
en kilomètres en voiture non effectué
pour conserver ça bon et c'est il y a
aussi ce genre de débat qui doivent être
installés dans la population et c'est
pas simple d'illustrer ce genre de débat
pour plein de raisons d'abord parce que
c'est pas simple d'illustrer le monde
dans 20 ans ou le ce qu'il pourrait être
dans les mauvais cas de figure dans 20
ans c'est un truc qui est compliqué et
c'est voilà mais c'est on est clairement
dans une discipline un peu nouvelle
qu'on va devoir apprendre que j'appelle
parfois la hiérarchie des renoncements
c'est-à-dire à quoi est-ce qu'on est
prêt à renoncer qu'est-ce qui va pas
être très coûteux finalement et
qu'est-ce qu'on a envie d'avoir en face
est-ce qu'on a envie d'avoir en face à
un monde qui nous paraît plus assuré par
exemple est-ce qu'on gagne de l'espoir
est-ce qu'on gagne de la sérénité est-ce
qu'on gagne de la sécurité est-ce qu'on
gagne des trucs comme ça qui ont pas qui
ont pas de valeur économique stricto
sensu mais qui ont quand même une valeur
importante pour les individus puisqu'on
est sur le sur la question des
la question du confort psychologique et
la question du des valeurs en fait
voilà il y a pas de réponse miracle donc
là c'est clair qu'on va tâtonner un peu
très probablement mais il me semble
qu'il est important dans le débat sur
ces terrains-là encore une fois qui est
la juste répartition de l'effort et le
fait par ailleurs de tenir un discours
adulte à la population et donc de pas
lui raconter trop de carabistouille sur
le cadre physique dans lequel on va être
obligé de réfléchir
sur la question de l'aménagement du
territoire là je vous renvoie à la aux
travaux du shift récent qui s'appelle
stratégie de résilience des territoires
on a fait tout un tout un ensemble de
travaux là dessus et c'est clair que là
aussi il faut déconcentrer pour partie
l'initiative face aux problèmes mais il
faut la déconcentrer de manière
intelligente c'est-à-dire que la bonne
manière de déconcentrer l'initiative
c'est de mettre les gens en capacité de
comprendre pour moi c'est ça la première
étape la première étage de la fusée de
façon et donc ça passe comme pour les
députés qui n'ont pas été très assidus à
la séance de formation qui vient d'avoir
lieu aussi j'ai bien compris ça passe
aussi pour les élus locaux par le fait
d'arriver à comprendre ce qui se passe
où sont leurs marges de manoeuvre et où
est-ce que ils doivent être fatalistes
quelque part même si c'est quelque chose
qu'on n'aime pas parce que ils vont se
retrouver face à plus fort que eux il va
falloir qu'ils composent avec une
évolution qui va de toute façon prendre
place
les on a la première recommandation
stratégie de résilience des territoires
c'était de consacrer 1% des budgets
sachant qu'il y a 10% du budget pour
plein de communes qui vont être bouffées
par la hausse de l'énergie 1% du budget
à de l'acquisition de connaissances
c'est-à-dire soit de la formation des
élus des agents etc soit de la des
études Haddock qui permettent de
comprendre quelle est la situation de
départ avec les forces et les faiblesses
du territoire sur lequel on est et
comment est-ce qu'on confronte le
territoire un objectif national qui est
d'arriver à se passer progressivement
des hydrocarbures sous contrainte de
métaux d'espace de biomasse et tout un
tas d'autres trucs et de biodiversité
enfin bref tout un tas de trucs
voilà et sur la question du salaire
universel j'ai pas de réponse à vous
apporter
en France on est plus proche avec les
systèmes de solidarité que nous avons
que d'autres pays de cette notion
puisque on a déjà un certain nombre de
revenus garantis dans un certain nombre
de cas de figures on a une un système de
chômage qui est une très bonne chose qui
permet de faire face à un certain nombre
de situations où les gens sont sans
ressource je n'ai pas les compétences
j'ai pas réfléchi à la question pour
savoir si il faut aller plus loin que ça
et dans quel sous quelle forme voilà
donc là Joker si j'ai envie de dire
c'est un peu hors de mon champ de
compétences et j'ai pas tellement de pas
tellement de questions
alors après il y a une question
qui m'a été posée
enfin toute une série de questions
[Musique]
alors je vais quand même faire une
remarque vous avez commencé par me dire
vous parlez beaucoup de la sobriété on
vous voit pas assez là-dessus puis
ensuite vous m'avez traité de
monomaniaque du nucléaire mais enfin si
je parle beaucoup de la sobriété je peux
pas être un mot de maniaque du nucléaire
je parle nécessairement d'autres choses
que du nucléaire bon
alors si on entend que sur le nucléaire
là il faut vous adresser au journaliste
il faut quand même savoir oui oui je
vais vous heurter une anecdote
lors du lancement du monde sans fin
excellente BD que vous avez sûrement lu
j'ai été invité à la matinale de France
Inter ils avaient commencé par m'inviter
pour parler de nucléaire je leur ai dit
je n'irai pas j'en ai marre qu'on vient
de me chercher juste pour ce sujet je
n'irai pas bon et alors ils m'ont dit
est-ce que vous voulez venir parler de
votre BD j'ai dit ça je veux bien donc
en fait la raison pour laquelle je suis
mis en avant et là en ce moment là comme
je vous parle la semaine qui vient de se
passer j'ai dû refuser je crois combien
entre 5 et 10 invitations à les causer
de nucléaire dans la presse donc je sais
pas moi enfin c'est pas moi j'assume mes
opinions mais le fait que vous ayez une
presse qui adore et vous êtes bien payé
pour le savoir les trucs qui sont blancs
et noirs une fois qu'on vous a collé
dans une case c'est difficile d'en
sortir donc par ailleurs je je n'élutte
pas et je donc quand je suis sur un
plateau de télé et qui a 10 questions
dont une question sur le nucléaire je
réponds à la question sur le nucléaire
je veux dire je suis pas là pour comment
dire ah bah non celle-là je répondrai
pas j'ai pas envie allez donc voir
quelqu'un d'autre j'assume mais cela
étant si derrière le résumé c'est qu'on
retient que ça
je fais ce que je peux pour lutter
contre je ne maîtrise pas complètement
le processus donc je
m'exprime également
par d'autres canaux que la presse en
particulier je m'exprime tous les jours
sur LinkedIn et je ne parle pas tous les
jours de nucléaire si vous allez
regarder loin sans faut je m'exprime
également sur mon site personnel et je
ne parle pas que de nucléaire loin sans
faut donc et je m'exprime dans des
vidéos où je ne parle pas que nucléaire
loin s'en fout je suis capable de faire
un exposé d'une heure et demie sur la
situation énergétique et climatique en
prononçant le mot nucléaire deux fois si
je le prononce donc voilà donc la seule
chose que je peux dire c'est autant que
faire ce peu j'essaye de renvoyer les
gens à mes écrits et à mes euros
primaires après la presse de temps en
temps vous la maîtrisez pas complètement
encore une fois vous êtes bien placé
pour le savoir
après je sais pas si je voulais que je
réponde dans le détail à toutes les
autres trucs que vous avez
bon j'ai compris que vous aimiez pas
beaucoup de nucléaires
je sais pas si c'est la peine de
répondre en détail tout
le sens de ma question est moi quand je
regarde Boutabout les éléments
rationnels et dont vous faites y compris
état dans un certain nombre d'écrits je
n'aboutis pas à la même conclusion c'est
pas une question d'idéologie c'est une
question de mettre bout à poule et chose
et c'est pour ça que je vous posais la
question sur les 15 années le
réchauffement climatique et sur
l'incertitude quelque part de
développement de la technologie qui que
vous mettez en exergue dans les options
et que vous défendez de fait et donc
c'est ça qui m'interroge réellement sur
pourquoi cette croyance quelque part
totale dans le fait que le nucléaire
sauverait le climat ce qui moi me paraît
antinomique mais c'est un peu ça voilà
c'était le sens de ma question ça
m'intéresse quand même votre réponse
alors si vous avez bien lu ce que j'ai
écrit et dit je n'ai jamais dit que le
nucléaire s'ouvrait le climat j'avais
j'ai toujours dit que le nucléaire
n'éviterait pas la décroissance toujours
j'ai toujours dit qu'il ne serait pas à
l'échelle pour remplacer les
combustibles fossiles toujours la seule
chose que je dis c'est que il fait
partie des amortisseurs de la
décroissance et dans cette catégorie là
je considère qu'il a un certain nombre
d'avantages physiques qui font que c'est
une bonne idée d'en faire autant qu'on
peut sachant qu'au temps qu'on peut ça
sera jamais des montagnes de toute façon
parce qu'il y a des limites temporelles
et de compétences sur son déploiement
qui font que de toute façon et j'ai
également écrit dans le premier livre
que j'ai écrit que l'énergie infinie
serait une absolue qui catastrophe je
l'ai écrit dès mon premier bouquin
explique si on était tous transformés en
Superman vous voyez vous avez une tête
qui me plaît pas je fais exposer cette
salle enfin donc ça sera une absolue
catastrophe que on est tous de l'énergie
limitée qu'elle soit propre ou sale
n'est pas le sujet
donc j'ai mais par contre j'ai toujours
dit que il fallait dans un monde
imparfait et qui va malheureusement
l'aide de plus en plus
hiérarchiser nos possibilités d'action
et choisir en premier là où la balance
avantage inconvénient est la plus
intéressante or je fais partie des gens
qui ne croient pas pour dire que pour
des raisons physiques on est rare
jusqu'au bout des scénarios de
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
diffuses électriques intermittentes donc
les trois adjectifs sont importants je
pense qu'on n'ira pas au bout parce que
il faudra c'est trop complexe comme
système
il y a quatre conditions physiques sur
lesquelles l'aïeux et RTE ont dit qu'il
fallait arriver à franchir une barrière
que pour le moment on n'est pas arrivé à
franchir il y a un petit document qui a
été diffusé il y a un an et demi je
crois à peu près je sais pas si vous
l'avez vu qui listaient les quatre les
quatre conditions
il y a un sujet de stockage un sujet
d'ajustement en fréquence il y a un
sujet de disponibilité
du il y a un sujet de
stockage inter saisonnier qui est un
truc très important en bref il y a un
certain nombre de conditions et je pense
que on n'y arrivera pas donc or le
système nucléaire on y est déjà arrivé
une fois en France donc on a fait la
preuve qu'au moins on est arrivé une
fois donc c'est exactement l'image qu'on
utilise dans le dans le monde sans fin
ça fait partie des parachutes de secours
mais vous avez un parachute de secours
c'est un truc dont vous avez pas envie
de vous servir déjà vous avez du sauté
de l'avion parce qu'il était en flamme
et en plus le parachute dorsale mange
pas donc voilà mais c'est quand même
quelque chose qui à tout prendre
présente des avantages supérieurs à ces
inconvénients voilà c'est ça mon opinion
en ayant bien regardé mon opinion sur le
nucléaire date d'une époque où je
n'avais pas touché un euro d'un acteur
de la filière nucléaire ça date du
moment où j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à
la question climatique en fait
chronologiquement j'ai regardé d'abord
le climat ensuite j'ai regardé le
nucléaire et ensuite j'ai regardé le
j'ai regardé chronologiquement dans ces
trois ordres là
et j'ai donc à l'époque j'étais pas
j'avais zéro lien économique avec ce
monde là juste j'ai été posé des tas de
questions et tant que j'avais pas
compris j'ai continué à les poser des
questions bon et c'est de cette époques
là que je date que date ma conviction
que c'est une énergie qui est à mettre
du côté des solutions et pas du côté des
problèmes voilà mais c'est pas parce que
c'est à mettre du côté des solutions que
c'est miracles j'ai jamais dit ça et je
ne le dirai jamais
merci bien du coup on a encore deux
questions que je vous propose de faire
assez et ça m'évitera pas des
informations de sobriété j'insiste
là-dessus ça le les évitera pas ça les
allège que je vous propose donc de merci
beaucoup monsieur Jean-Côme ici je vous
propose de faire les questions courtes
et synthétiques Madame brûlebois et
Monsieur Mazar
plaisir de vous écouter vous êtes une
figure incontournable de la
sobriété de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique vous parler
vrai vous parlez simple vous parlez
juste et vous plaisez beaucoup aux jeux
aux jeux de générations votre chaîne
Youtube compte 220000 abonnés votre
facebook 185000 lignes de kind 600 mille
abonnés pardon
voilà donc moi ce qui m'inquiète
voyez-vous c'est c'est ce numérique qui
est sur la pente ascendante qui augmente
de 9% sur un an et bref ce numérique
risque de devenir insoutenable pour la
planète puisque c'est un gouffre
énergétique un grand consommateur de
matière première donc le secteur du
numérique génère autant de gaz à effet
plus de gaz à effet de serre que
l'aviation que vous avez souvent cité et
2017-2050 on nous dit que à ce rythme
elle représenteront 35% des émissions
des émissions en haut de gaz à effet de
serre donc ma question est la suivante
ce numérique qui a quelque peu quand
même bénéficié à l'environnement
ne suffit pas à compenser sa propre
empreinte numérique on a pensé
on a compté sur la dématérialisation
pour économiser des arbres mais au bout
du compte quand on fait l'addition le
compte pas alors que pensez-vous
Monsieur Jean comme site de
cette ce développement exponentiel de
ces tweets retweets futile
inutiles pensez-vous qu'il ne faudrait
pas aujourd'hui réfléchir à
responsabiliser voire à réguler l'usage
du numérique
merci Monsieur Mazar merci synthétique
merci monsieur le Président désolé
monsieur donc ici je vais vous obliger
encore à parler un petit peu de
nucléaire
quand on rencontre nos concitoyens alors
qu'ils sont pas farouchement au stylo
nucléaire ils expriment donc deux
craintes concernant le nucléaire la
première crainte et vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure c'est quid des déchets et
vous avez dit que c'était peut-être un
peu disproportionné la crainte qu'on
pouvait avoir sur le traitement de l'eau
déchets par rapport à la technologie qui
semble assez
assez
efficace à la matière mais en tout cas
le peu de risque objectif qui que
représente ces déchets et après la
deuxième crème qui est exprimée c'est la
sécurisation des sites même des sites
nucléaires par rapport aux catastrophes
nucléaires ou par rapport à des attaques
et on voit ce qui se passe à l'Ukraine
actuellement quel est votre votre avis
là pour pour pourquoi pas aussi rassurer
nos concitoyens sur ce sujet ou est-ce
que c'est une crainte qu'il faut prendre
véritablement au sérieux
et qui peut être un écueil au
développement du nucléaire et puis un
mot sur sur l'énergie produit par nos
grands ouvrages hydroélectriques vous
savez que qu'aujourd'hui certaines
normes de ces ouvrages
sont exploitées par
des exploitants historiques mais à qui
on demande donc de remettre donc à la
concurrence donc fin demande à l'état en
tout cas de remettre la concurrence donc
d'exploitation de ces grands barrages
hydroélectriques alors là on est sur un
problème de souveraineté qui est palier
à la technologie ou aux procédures mais
qui est liée donc à celui qui demain
pourrait piloter ces grands ouvrages
quelle est votre sentiment sur le sujet
et est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'orientation qui semble être prise
concernant notamment l'opérateur EDF
avec la nationalisation semble aller
dans le bon dans la bonne direction
alors madame Babou et puis ensuite on
aura fini des questions
merci monsieur le Président oui je
voulais tout d'abord revenir sur les
dérivés du plastique du pétrole dont
vous évoquez si vous pouvez
éventuellement développer vous avez
parlé de la mobilité des bâtiments mais
restait effectivement les plastiques du
quotidien et notamment dans la partie
alimentaire
la deuxième question c'est sur le bilan
de carbone sur le bilan carbone vous en
êtes l'auteur on parle souvent des
missions carbone mais bien moins de
bilan et pour nos prises de décision je
pense qu'il serait intéressant et
j'aimerais savoir si ça si cela existe
alors dans de nombreux domaines mais
aussi sur l'énergie un bilan carbone sur
l'ensemble des solutions que nous avons
évoquées quelque chose de précis et de
clair qui serait ma collègue parlait
tout à l'heure de rationnel là au moins
ce serait intangible ce serait factuel
merci
voilà alors on vous laissant la parole
je vous pose une dernière question un
peu bonus
voilà privilège du président
cuite des fuites carbone
autre que naturel
vous voulez parler de l'aspirateur à CO2
islandais
alors
de numérique vous avez raison j'ai
mauvaise conscience
bah oui
le numérique je vais d'abord le relier à
la au thème de cette commission c'est un
domaine dans lequel nous n'avons aucune
souveraineté aucune c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui pour payer mes impôts je
dépends des gafas
et à la fonction la plus régalienne de
l'État qui devait l'impôt a été confié
au Gafa j'ai besoin d'un ordinateur
j'ai besoin d'un système internet qui
est pas opéré j'ai besoin d'un système
mondial de télécommunications tout ça il
y a plus rien de il y a plus rien dans
cette affaire qui relève de la
souveraineté française
le ce qu'on vient de faire sur la 5G de
mon point de vue un abandon
supplémentaire de souveraineté puisque
on va obliger les français enfin on va
obliger on va inciter pour être plus
exact les opérateurs français à
s'équiper avec des tas de composants de
réseau qui sont pas fabriqués en France
on va inciter les Français à changer de
smartphone pour des appareils qui sont
pas fabriqués en France donc c'est
quelque chose qui est tout ça pour
regarder Netflix dans le métro enfin je
suis pas complètement convaincu et pour
avoir tinder qui marche mieux du reste
au moins Free et honnête dans ses
campagnes de pub donc le opération du
genou de madame je sais pas quoi en
Creuse là en fait non c'est pas ça que
ça va servir donc on a on est clairement
aujourd'hui dans ce que j'appelle les
briété numérique alors avant de savoir
si la première chose à faire est de
fermer le compte Youtube de gens comme
ici ce qui est une option puisque comme
ça on s'est barbarie ça supprimera de la
pollution numérique
je fais ce que je peux regarder en très
basse définition mais bon c'est clair
que j'y participe aussi donc ça question
pour moi aussi
il y a quand même alors si on repart du
début l'empreinte carbone du numérique
aujourd'hui dans le monde c'est à moitié
fabrication des équipements à moitié
opération des équipements dans les
équipements vous avez tous les écrans
connectés là qui sont autour de cette
table enfin autour de cette salle pardon
vous avez les ordinateurs vous avez les
smartphones vous avez les composants de
réseau voilà ça c'est les serveurs et
l'opération de ces équipements donc
l'électricité c'est l'autre moitié ce
qui tire aujourd'hui extrêmement
fortement donc vous avez raison de me
chatouiller sur Youtube ce qui tire
aujourd'hui extrêmement fortement la
croissance du trafic du système digital
mondial c'est la vidéo en ligne alors
les gens qui font du streaming la
Netflix en tête YouTube et tu as un gros
pourvoyeur également de trafic data le
porno est également un gros pourvoyeur
de trafic data et après vous avez toutes
les vidéos du petit dernier qui fait à
eux que les gens s'envoient
et qui est quelque chose de nul
important pour en général pour les
récipendaires mais très important pour
les gens qui expédient la vidéo et donc
le
donc la question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on limite l'inflation de tout ça
alors il y a quelques suggestions qu'on
avait faites à l'époque au chiffre
projet on avait proposé à la recette que
les accords enfin que les licences
octroyées aux opérateurs soient faites
sous conditions de maîtrise de
l'empreinte carbone
option
à l'époque il nous avait qu'à moitié
rayonné en fait il nous avait ils
avaient noté l'idée voilà il faudra
probablement c'est toujours pareil à
partir du moment où on veut limiter un
usage avec deux options un c'est des
quantités ou les prix et aussi project
on est un peu plus communiste donc on
préfère les quantités que les prix on
pense que c'est plus égalitaire de
limiter par les quantités que de limiter
par les prix
il va clairement falloir se poser la
question et par ailleurs aujourd'hui la
débauche d'équipements qu'on est en
train d'utiliser pour des usages
totalement récréatifs le métaverse etc
donc je ne suis pas complètement
convaincu qu'ils vont aider à faire
pleuvoir ou à se sortir un peu mieux de
la situation qu'on est en train de
décrire ici c'est autant de composants
qu'on ne pourra plus mettre dans des
choses qui aujourd'hui sont
indispensables au fonctionnement
quotidien de notre société avoir des
banques aujourd'hui les banques c'est
quoi c'est des électrons et des
ordinateurs c'est ça une banque
aujourd'hui c'est d'accord sans sans
électronique ça n'existe plus une banque
si demain matin on devait revenir au
billet de banque et au comptable sur
feuille de papier système explose donc
c'est ces usages-là qui sont même si on
dit beaucoup de mal des banques par
ailleurs il y a des usages comme ça qui
aujourd'hui sont devenus essentiels à
très court terme
et on est en train de entre guillemets
gaspiller des ressources pour des trucs
assez futile au détriment de la
possibilité de garder des trucs qu'on va
devoir garder un peu plus longtemps plus
longtemps précisément voilà donc il y a
un vrai sujet là-dessus il me semble que
ça justifierait également des
investigations un peu plus approfondie
de l'enceinte dans laquelle je me trouve
de se pencher sur qu'est-ce qu'on fait
en termes de stratégie numérique dans ce
pays à part céder à la fascination
devant le gadget et je suis désolé de le
dire à votre groupe notre président en
tête
alors
ensuite en ce qui concerne on va quand
même tous vu au Consumer Show de Las
Vegas avec des lunettes virtuelles etc
enfin bon
après il y avait un sujet sur la
sécurisation
des sites enfin la question des
accidents sur les sites
alors les
un accidents toujours possible c'est
clair que il faut vivre avec cette idée
moi en sortant d'ici je peux me faire
renverser par un camion donc un accident
est toujours possible
la question c'est est-ce que compte tenu
des avantages que nous offre les
dispositifs non accidentés on est prêt à
courir le risque de l'accident et le
risque de l'accident aujourd'hui le plus
important c'est le risque de panique en
fait c'est pas tellement le risque c'est
pas tellement le dommage physique lié à
l'accident c'est le fait qu'aujourd'hui
le nucléaire encore une fois j'ai jamais
percé complètement les raisons de tout
ça
engendre des réactions qui sont
disproportionnées par rapport à la
cigarette par rapport à la circulation
routière ou par rapport à un aliment
dont je ne redonnerai pas le nom ici
parce que ça a déjà suffisamment fait le
buzz comme ça mais c'est mais voilà
quand on regarde les risques concours en
fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe en cas d'accident
sur un réacteur à eau pressurisé le plus
probable c'est qu'il se passe la même
chose que ce qui s'est passé à TRIMA
Island c'est à dire que vous perdez le
réacteur à l'intérieur de l'enceinte de
confinement point qu'est-ce qui se passe
si vous avez un conflit alors à ce
moment le vrai problème c'est est-ce que
l'accident enfin la vraie question c'est
est-ce que l'accident va rajouter de
façon massive des dommages par rapport
aux dommages du conflit
c'est ça la question donc la question
c'est s'il y a un accident à sauridja
est-ce que ça change significativement
le bilan de la guerre en Ukraine et la
réponse est malheureusement non
donc quand il y a un dommage à une
installation parce qu'il y a une guerre
le vrai problème c'est la guerre c'est
quand même ça le vrai problème c'est
bien ça qu'il faut comprendre
après vous avez des tas de manière de
faire plein de morts avec des dommages
aux installations de production
électrique et du reste dans la même la
convention
j'adore les guerres avec convention je
veux bien que tu me tues et d'une
certaine manière seulement
normalement on ne porte pas atteinte au
centrale nucléaire quand on se fait la
guerre mais on ne porte pas non plus
atteinte au barrage figurez-vous et or
si vous voulez faire beaucoup de dégâts
très rapidement on voit beaucoup mieux
beaucoup mieux dézinguer les barrages
que dézinguer les centrales nucléaires
si on faisait sauter le barrage de
Vouglans en France ça mettrait 6 mètres
d'eau place Bellecour à Lyon je peux
vous assurer que ça ferait plus de morts
que bon donc c'est c'est donc c'est quoi
la c'est quoi la bonne réponse en fait
elle tient dans un mot que j'ai pas
prononcé jusqu'à maintenant qui est
pédagogique
l'époque va probablement demander que
votre métier comporte plus qu'avant
le fait de faire la pédagogie des
problèmes alors je sais bien que pour un
élu normalement on fait la pédagogie des
solutions mais non mais de temps en
temps je pense que vous allez pas couper
au fait de faire aussi la pédagogie des
problèmes de peau la seule manière d'y
arriver c'est de vous en imprégner
vous-même c'est à dire d'être vous-même
capable de maîtriser à peu près les
sujets sur le plan technique alors ça en
fait de plus je sais très bien que ça
vient en plus de la sécurité sociale de
la production agricole de la façon dont
on enseigne le français au collège et de
ce qui se passe dans les quartiers où il
y a trop d'immigrés donc ça vient en
plus de tout ça mais
il va falloir le faire quand même
quand je dis trop c'est pas un jugement
de valeur c'est pour représenter le
débat public
pardon
vous pouvez le laisser c'est une figure
de style
après il y avait un sujet sur une
question sur l'hydroélectricité
et du coup j'ai pas noté la question
j'ai juste noté que c'était l'hydro
alors l'ouverture à la concurrence du
site ouais alors je me suis je me suis
exprimé de manière générale sur
l'ouverture à la concurrence des
systèmes électriques en disant que ça
avait été une connerie
et je le pense toujours que on a
essentiellement perdu notre temps à
faire quelque chose qui n'a apporté
aucun mais aucun élément positif rien ça
servait à rien ça a servi à enrichir des
distributeurs ça a servi à divertir de
la rente par rapport aux propriétaires
des dispositifs de production ça a servi
à créer des effets de volatilité dans
les prix de marché dont en ce moment on
est en train de voir les effets à plein
ça a servi à rien utile voilà donc
est-ce qu'il faut aller encore plus loin
dans cette direction bah vous avez la
réponse la réponse est non
qu'est-ce que ça demande de rétropédaler
sur ce sujet bah ça demande que la
France prenne son bâton de pèlerin et
ail commencer à militer et donc faire la
pédagogie du problème aussi auprès de
nos amis européens puisque c'est une ça
dépend d'une décision en disant que
peut-être que l'époque voudrais que on
arrête ce genre de système qui n'a
strictement aucun intérêt et que on
revienne à quelque chose de plus intégré
qui permet de faire de la planification
sur le long terme parce que le maître
mot en matière de système énergétique
c'est de planifier et quand vous avez un
marché ouvert la planification est
impossible
donc vous pouvez faire de la délégation
on aurait pu faire de l'ouverture à
Lamont sur on aurait pu dire bon on fait
un duopole dans ce pays quand on en a
marre des DF on prend engie quand on en
a marre d'engie on prend un DF on sait
exactement ce qu'on a fait dans l'eau
c'est ce qu'on vous avez plein de dans
les infrastructures très capitalistiques
c'est ce qui finit par se passer
c'est-à-dire oligopole régulé on peut
discuter de savoir si un oligopole
régulé c'est mieux qu'un monopole
d'accord mais c'est le seul truc qui est
qui qui soit compatible avec le fait que
vous avez besoin d'opérateurs capables
d'assumer des investissements lourds
voilà la concurrence à Laval était un
truc qui n'avait aucun intérêt
alors les usages du plastique on peut
faire de des plastiques avec de la
chimie avec de la biomasse puisque dans
les hydrocarbures et du carbone et de
l'hydrogène donc dans la biomasse vous
pouvez récupérer du carbone et de
l'hydrogène et après pareil faire des
faire des plastiques tu restes
aujourd'hui vous avez des plastiques qui
sont faits à partir des thanol de canne
à sucre à partir d'un million de mètres
etc
est-ce qu'on en fera autant que le
plastique qu'on fait avec le vrai
pétrole je ne sais pas est-ce que ça
sera aussi facile ça non ça sera
nécessairement plus compliqué
et après la question c'est à partir du
moment où on tape dans la biomasse en
fait il y a toujours une question
systémique à laquelle il faut être enfin
le système à laquelle il faut être
capable de répondre la biomasse
c'est-à-dire l'espace vous pouvez en
faire quatre choses différentes vous
pouvez vous en servir pour manger vous
pouvez vous en servir pour avoir des
matériaux des fibres du bois du chanvre
du lin etc du coton vous pouvez vous en
servir pour avoir de l'énergie
du bois bûche cette fois-ci pas du bois
d'or des agrocarbures etc et vous pouvez
vous en servir pour fiche la paix à ce
qui s'y trouve ça s'appelle préserver la
biodiversité et de temps en temps vous
pouvez un peu combiner les usages par
exemple vous pouvez faire une
agriculture qui soit plus ou moins
nocive pour la biodiversité donc vous
pouvez avoir des des combinaisons vous
pouvez faire de l'agriculture avec de
l'agroforesterie avoir un peu de bois
énergie ou avoir un peu de bois
matériaux un peu combiné
il faut bien voir aussi qu'à l'avenir le
changement climatique va peser sur les
rendements agricoles la décrue de la
disponibilité fossile va peser sur les
rendements agricoles puisque en fait
quand on mange aujourd'hui on mange du
pétrole et du gaz on mange du pétrole
dans la mécanisation des engins de
transport et dans les transports amont
et aval j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure et
on mange du gaz dans la fabrication des
engrais azotées qui sont faits avec du
gaz donc dans la décrue on mange
également des engrais qui sont importés
très loin des phosphates et de la
potasse c'est l'exploitation minière
donc avec ces on mange en faire du
pétrole pour les phytosanitaires bon
avec la décrue de tout ça on va vous
savez que la mécanisation les
phytosanitaires et les engrais on fait
on multiplier le rendement céréaliers en
France par 5 en 30 ans après guerre
c'est évident que dans un monde avec un
climat plus hostile et avec moins de
combustibles fossiles disponibles on va
avoir une partie du chemin inverse qui
va se faire
question est-ce qu'on accepte par
exemple de manger moins de viande en
ayant pas plus de surface agricole
est-ce que on veut plus de surface
agricole pour manger toujours autant de
viande du coup vous aurez moins de
surfaces agricoles pour faire du bois
d'oeuvre du bois énergie et pour faire
des plastiques enfin oui donc c'est très
difficile de répondre à cette question
là de façon dissocier de la façon dont
on répond à plein d'autres questions y
compris sous contrainte enfin ou en
incluant plus exactement la contrainte
d'approvisionnement énergétique fossile
et la contrainte de dérive climatique
qui sont plutôt des choses qui vont
jouer dans le mauvais sens globalement
donc la réponse pour faire court c'est
qu'il va falloir en utiliser moins
et manger moins de viande c'est pas ou
c'est
voilà et après il va bien il va falloir
bien la choisir donc typiquement dans le
moins de viande qu'on mange c'est
évident qu'il faut d'abord commencer par
préserver ce qui vient des pâturages
parce que c'est des endroits où
valorisés plus facilement de la biomasse
avec des animaux et moins avec ceux qui
vient des grandes cultures qui vont
servir derrière à nourrir des animaux
etc enfin bon il y a tout de suite tout
un débat à voir là dedans également qui
a un débat pas simple et il faut bien
voir aussi que il y a un vrai sujet dans
cette affaire
un aparté mais c'est très difficile de
demander un secteur qui est pas
globalement pas très riche à l'exception
de quelques acteurs mais qui est
l'agriculture
de faire des innovations massives sans
que les Français acceptent de payer leur
nourriture un peu plus cher donc on a
aussi un sujet à ce niveau là
alors il y avait le bilan carbone des
sources énergétiques alors oui il y a
des sources énergétiques sur lesquelles
c'est très simple de faire une empreinte
carbone par exemple tous les modes
électriques c'est raisonnablement simple
avec parfois des variations par exemple
un panneau solaire selon vous le mettez
dans un désert chilien ou selon vous le
mettez dans la brume norvégienne il va
pas vous sortir la même quantité qui le
même panneau solaire qui aura émis la
même quantité de CO2 pour sa fabrication
parce qu'il faut de la métallurgie parce
qu'il faut fondre le silicium parce que
etc Il vous fera pas la même quantité de
kilowattheure à l'arrivée sur sa durée
de vie et donc le contenu carbone en
analyse de cycle de vie du
kilowatt-heure produit aura varié par la
force des choses mais on a quand même
des ordres de grandeur donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui est assez facile à
établir là où ça commence à devenir plus
difficile c'est pour certaines énergies
fossiles d'estimer les émissions que
dites fugitives c'est-à-dire les
émissions qui sont liées à les fuites à
Lamont et particulièrement pour le gaz
puisque le gaz naturel c'est du méthane
et que le méthane est un gaz à effet de
serre donc les fuites de gaz naturel de
mémoire je vais pas dire de bêtises mais
de mémoire à 10% 8% de fuite le gaz
naturel est aussi nocif que le charbon
pour le voilà 8%, on les a pas en
général mais quelques pour cent on peut
les avoir
donc il y a après pour des là où ça
devient plus compliqué c'est pas
tellement pour les sources énergétiques
c'est pour tout ce qui en est issus
c'est-à-dire si je veux faire
l'empreinte carbone de votre foulard
l'empreinte carbone de votre veste ou
l'empreinte carbone de ce micro là ça
devient plus compliqué parce que à
chaque fois il faut faire une
investigation approfondie sur les
sources énergétiques globalement les
ordres de grandeur sont assez facilement
disponibles là où vous allez avoir une
incertitude importante c'est sur les
sources issues de la biomasse parce que
ça renvoie la discussion qu'on a déjà eu
plusieurs fois c'est est-ce que c'est
associé à de la déforestation ou pas
parce que ça change le résultat d'un
ordre de grandeur en gros si c'est pas
associé à de la déforestation c'est
mieux que le fossile mais si c'est
associé à de la déforestation c'est pire
que les fossiles donc c'est là là il y a
quelque chose qui est vraiment
[Musique]
j'ai envie de dire ça fait vraiment
changer de résultat de nature et c'est
lié à quelque chose sur lequel vous
pouvez faire difficilement autrement que
de poser des hypothèses
alors le
dans les plus émissives vous allez
trouver en CO2 ça dépend ça dépend sur
quel paramètre par ailleurs parce que
vous pouvez regarder le CO2 vous pouvez
regarder l'espace au sol vous pouvez
regarder les particules fines voilà
alors si on parle de CO2 ce qui est la
plus nocive de le très loin c'est le
charbon ensuite arrive le pétrole
ensuite arrive le gaz mais le bois avec
des forestations c'est encore pire que
le charbon d'accord donc par exemple les
projets qui visent à remplacer pour un
certain nombre de pays où le bois de feu
est obtenu par déforestation les foyers
par des petits réchaud à gaz c'est pas
idiot
sans même parler de foyer solaire du
Butagaz de camping voilà donc
vous avez un donc c'est ça la hiérarchie
dans les modes donc dit non carbonés
c'est-à-dire où le fonctionnement même
n'aimait pas de CO2
la hiérarchie c'est que vous allez
trouver au plus haut vous allez trouver
le solaire en dessous vous allez trouver
à peu près à parité l'hydroélectricité
l'éolien et le nucléaire avec des
petites variations en fonction des
spécificités locales voilà mais en gros
c'est comme ça que ça se avec un facteur
3 4 on va dire entre le solaire et le et
le reste le reste vous êtes entre 5 et
10 g de CO2 par kilowattheure électrique
le solaire vous êtes entre 20 et 50 en
fonction de des conditions d'insolation
etc
ça c'est sans tenir compte du stockage
parce que quand vous stockez vous perdez
20 à 40 % enfin avec des modes
classiques donc soit step step vous
perdez 25% batterie vous perdez 20% et
il faut faire la batterie
ce qui émet également du CO2 comme vous
le savez probablement dans une voiture
électrique la fabrication de la batterie
c'est la moitié des émissions de
fabrication de la voiture donc si vous
rajoutez les émissions du stockage pour
le soleil vous pouvez dépasser les 100 g
en mode purement électrique le gaz est à
400 g de CO2 par kWh électrique le
pétrole à 800 et le charbon à 1000 en
ordre de grandeur
les puits de carbone technologiques bon
entre en très court vous oubliez
il y a un truc qui technologiquement
peut fonctionner c'est de ne pas émettre
c'est-à-dire la capture et séquestration
mais récupérer le CO2 une fois qu'il est
dans l'air avec des modes technologiques
ça c'est un truc de Shadok
le CO2 est une molécule qui est
chimiquement inerte
c'est chimiquement inerte le CO2 une
fois que vous avez une molécule
chimiquement inerte diluée à 0,04% dans
un milieu aussi peu dense que l'air
et bien pour aller récupérer le CO2 là
dedans vous avez une dépense énergétique
qui est tellement considérable
que en fait c'est un truc que vous ne
pourrez jamais déployer à l'échelle
alors j'ai fait un petit calcul d'ordre
de grandeur avec le truc islandais qui a
fait un peu le buzz l'aspirateur assez
en deux islandais et mon calcul c'est
que si on voulait avec ce genre de
dispositif qui s'appelle dans le jargon
anglais donc DAC la totalité de nos
émissions annuelles
reprendre dans l'atmosphère après avoir
émis la totalité de nos émissions
annuelles il faudrait y consacrer la
totalité de l'électricité annuelle et la
totalité du pétrole consommait dans le
monde tous les ans donc en gros on
aurait un truc de Shadok parfait où
l'énergie ne servirait qu'à une chose
c'est à récupérer le CO2 qu'on met dans
l'air grâce à cause de l'énergie voilà
bon je suis pas complètement persuadé
que ce soit quelque chose
derrière lequel il fasse se précipiter
donc aujourd'hui comme l'argent coule à
flot partout parce qu'il y a eu la
création monétaire dans tous les sens
vous trouvez quelques fonds
d'investissement qui investissent dans
ce genre de trucs mais c'est voilà ça
les occupe mais en gros ça ne servira à
peu près à rien pour changer le destin
du monde
merci donc pour cette conclusion par
laquelle vous nous
inviter à penser que pour l'instant le
génie de l'homme n'a pas encore régalé
la photosynthèse en gros
c'est génial va avoir beaucoup de mal à
y aller un certain nombre de merveilles
de la nature vous savez on est d'accord
là
[Musique]
-dessus consacré à répondre aux
questions de notre commission d'enquête
ça permet de brosser large et de et de
progressivement entrer dans les sujets
qui seront peut-être davantage les
processus décisionnels que les choix
technologiques parce que ça contribue
aussi à la façon dont on prendra pendant
le dans le futur les décisions publiques
merci à toutes et à tous pour votre
participation et puis je vous dis bah à
la semaine prochaine monsieur le
rapporteur